wake up gamers it's time for trash taste
it's time for trash taste god that's
like
wake up gamers it's time for trash taste
i am your host for today gant and with
me are a bunch of sleepy boys
i just get reminded of the honey wake up
new trash taste episode
i love that is that energy uh yeah i'm
your host for today and uh with me is
connor and joey i'm so just
disinterested in yeah
i mean he's been we've been around for
we've been around for like 90 years
he's like
i don't [ __ ] know him
wake me up when they become the men then
then i'll be woke then i'll be working i
don't know if you know my username but
uh i'm growing yeah
i'm the only man in here i think we are
since we all shaved at all the same time
i wonder like who's who's growing he's
going to grow back the fastest now i
think we're all kind of growing at the
same rate yeah you got black you got a
black beard
you got to wait you got a black what you
got a black beard got a black bear why
does that matter because that means my
favorite one-piece character
badass pirate back yeah yeah uh
really lacking in uh
creativity with this pirate's name um
but
and obviously
you're
wait till i tell you about whitebeard
you'll never believe what he looks like
finish your sentence
conor black is darker
than brown yes
okay thank you what a hot song thank you
okay can we can we check that can
someone factor that stuff
out more it stands out more yeah well
let's get the ruler out let's uh let's
let's get the ruler if you want to if
you if we want to go we're going down to
the middle
does your face feel heavier with
blackheads
[Laughter]
i know black paint is heavier than white
paint is that true yeah
is it actually yeah
that sounds like it could be true but
that also sounds like it could be
complicated so are you saying so are you
saying that a head of black hair is
heavy i don't believe any other color of
hair
well on that scale where your hair is
not of a significant like
weight in general right i think it's
very minimal but like let's say i
learned this because i was like i was
looking at like weird uh ways that uh
planes save costs yeah which actually
ties in nicely to auto layer travel yes
travel so if you're traveling yes the
reason why you don't see black planes
oh because they're heavier it's heavier
i thought it would just would have cost
a lot to paint the damn thing well no
they paint it white
oh i i would have thought they painted a
wire because of reflection yeah
or maybe the heat that is
twice as heavy i believe black paint is
twice as heavy as white paint damn okay
i didn't know that well uh white hair is
thicker than black hair so i don't know
that's that's just enough paint that's
just like black hair nerfing yourself
because obviously because like that's
that's that's like nature doing a
balance patch right it's something to do
with the pigments
that's the weirdest balance patch i've
ever heard white hair is thicker than
black hair because black hair is heavier
than white god's like shave off a few
pounds yeah we got a little level of
playing field right now i got it wrong
white paint contains higher solid
content than black paint so white paints
actually solid content no no no no no
referring to athletes referring to
airplanes
yeah no that's what's there so wait so
white paint is heavier than black paint
yeah because they require more pigment
to achieve the same level of saturation
so then i'm sure i'm pretty sure that's
wrong so then why do we not have black
planes yeah this is considered this is i
think i think the i think it's not that
deep i think it's purely just because it
reflects more of the sun and it doesn't
turn the plane into a you know [ __ ]
oven we're sounding like [ __ ] flat
earthers right now yeah yeah yeah why
why play white paint's clearly heavier
okay yeah this this is this is the this
is the reasoning behind it i have is
that what a flat earth
but have you seen a black plane before
how do you know
we've clearly never been around the
world the same amount of like
pseudoscience we're saying right now i
feel like no none of us are even close
to scientists and uh we can like you
could logically make uh an argument for
both i feel yeah and uh come out on top
but uh i don't we don't uh even if the
if even the fact checkers i mean to be
fair oh yeah it would make sense if the
planes were black because
like then it'd be easier to spot in the
sky right
no it would be harder to spot in the
night time
right because it would be like
completely invisible then but it's
completely invisible anyway
this is so confusing you can't see a
bright white plane in the night
when i googled uh does black paint way
more than white paint google said white
paint weighs more but then i got another
article that says
uh black paint weighs more so bottom
line we don't [ __ ] say bottom line
nobody knows no one knows
we we cannot even scientists can't even
agree with each other if black or white
is heavier than each other have you ever
been in a plane that wasn't painted
white
uh i've been believe i have the ugliest
plane i've ever been on it was like a
shade of like you you i was with you
easyjet isn't that it was like it was
like a shade of like highlighter oranges
oh that is that is [ __ ] disgusting
it's a gross color i know they paint it
so that they don't have to like keep
like fixing the impurities on the chrome
or whatever oh is that what it is yeah
yeah because it's it's cheaper to just
paint it again
i thought it was like a branding thing
uh well i mean obviously it's like well
we have to paint it to save costs yeah
as well brand it a little bit yeah but
is it heavier than white or black paint
probably it's probably heavier but maybe
the branding is like worth it it's
probably lighter right because it's easy
jet so it's got to be cheaper
surely surely yeah i don't know that is
yeah i guess now that i think about it i
think that's the only
hey like only plane i've been on that's
like completely different color from
white i've never eaten
i've been on the pikachu plane i was
gonna say that apa aside from the pizza
i thought i was going to be more excited
getting on that plane but then i
realized i can't see you can't see it
just looks like a plane this is what it
feels like to get a sick skin in a first
person game it's like it's like do you
want a badass skin then i can't yeah
that actually is
amazing what's the point what's the
point i never got that why do people
care about skins in first person games
so you can flex it on other people
because you see some other people you
see your arms and that's pretty much it
it's to show dominance amongst your
fellow players yeah to make them know if
you have the samurai armor and halo you
have an absolute massive [ __ ]
i obviously have not played enough first
person games but we're not talking about
games today what are we talking about
because i thought it'd be fun to
actually do a themed episode it's been a
while since we've done a themed episode
right the music episode was the last
this is the most scuffed themed episode
by the way
we haven't written anything down we're
just like winging it yeah i mean i mean
i mean okay by themed episode we have a
topic that i hope we're gonna stick to
i'm not okay i'm not gonna get it i'm
not gonna guarantee that we're gonna
stick together i guarantee we'll talk
about among us in 20 minutes
but uh i i feel like now that we're
getting ready to travel and now that it
seems like the country is slowly opening
back up i mean at the time of recording
uh japan have finally let in you know uh
work visas and student visas after like
what two years is it like two and a half
two years and who knows what the
situation is going to be like now when
this episode actually is released maybe
the country will be open and maybe a
bunch of you are going to be traveling
to japan for tourism and stuff like that
you know best case scenario is that
before the year ends people start coming
so hopefully this episode will come in
handy when you do eventually come to
japan yeah but uh
i mean so like probably gonna be a while
though yeah
lots of lots of time to plan out well
yeah you know like many people pointed
out japan unfortunately uh has an
extremely older population
and older people don't really leave
japan and a lot of them have never left
japan never even gone out of the country
yeah so a lot of the people i think it's
like 80 or 70 90 percent of people agree
with the travel
ban right yeah whereas other countries
you know like europe uk it's like well
i've got to have a holiday in benidorm
oh my cousin's from who lives in
portland because people in the uk want
the country to be open because otherwise
they'd be stuck in the uk and where the
[ __ ] is there to go on a holiday in the
uk butlins
yeah which is why it sucks because like
obviously a lot of people from america
europe don't really understand why japan
isn't opening up and it's like well you
need to kind of understand the
japan puts like probably the most amount
of effort into their domestic tourism
yeah i mean that ties into the whole
elderly population yeah
people like i want to travel but i don't
want to get on a plane yeah i know i'll
get on a bullet train and go somewhere
completely different yeah it's you know
but let's just be optimistic
i'll be i'll stop being one customer
let's just be optimistic and let's be
like you know what maybe maybe the old
people will uh change their minds and be
like you know what you know what tourism
tourism good right
single wars started because the old ones
pretty much
so so yeah so let's say japan is open
and you are planning a trip to japan and
you've heard us talk about a [ __ ] ton of
things um in like about close to like a
hundred episodes now so you don't you
don't know where to look because we've
we've been talking about japan for what
about about japan for 100 episodes so
you don't really know even where to
start or maybe we've set a location
place and you're like what or who is
that yeah so we thought it'd be fun to
just have an episode where it's just
cl like collectively what we actually
recommend or don't recommend about japan
if you're gonna plan our trip use this
episode as like a placeholder just to
listen to it and be like oh that sounds
interesting and if the place sucks you
can blame us
pretty much
obviously it depends on how long you're
going for that's the best yeah yes we're
talking about five days
maybe you can still go out of tokyo yeah
but five days you can very easily just
stay in tokyo and have a great time the
first two times i came to japan i never
left
yeah exactly mainly because i was scared
um and of the old
people they're going to beat me
i mean you know using the shinkansens
and stuff is kind of intimidating it is
daunting yeah if no one's ever like
helped you do it yeah no it's it's it's
intimidating because obviously in tokyo
there's a safety net because a lot of
things in tokyo are built with the
idea that there's going to be people
from abroad coming to visit right so a
lot of places a lot of places have you
know english menu still you know you uh
it's way more it's way more friendly and
open whereas if you go outside of tokyo
you want to go eat and you're just like
okay this restaurant probably doesn't
have english on it dark souls
like this this 70 year old shop owner
has probably never seen a foreigner in
her life exactly exactly and it is
daunting you know even even nowadays for
for
uh for us even though if even though
we're well traveled you know sometimes
you know i i can do it but like
sometimes i have to like psych myself up
i'm japanese and i get intimidated yeah
because they look at me and they're like
you're not japanese
i don't know when it happened i just
stopped giving a [ __ ] about being awful
at japanese like a few months ago yeah
so now i just talk and then i get over
it yeah i don't i don't know if i do
good but i always get what i need
yeah so whether or not i'm doing it
right or not i get my i get my tonkatsu
yeah exactly um but yeah like just
pretend okay
you're you've just landed and you're on
a trip with the boys we're gonna show
you around we're gonna show you around
it's your first time to japan life hack
number one okay fly to hannibal don't
[ __ ] fly to narrative yes actually
actually that is that is that's like
that is number one top three locations
in japan that suck ass narrator airport
i mean
it might not be it might not be like
you might not be able to avoid anything
on which airline you fly with like if
you're cuz i know like a lot of the
major airlines like i think like
emirates and all those yeah you'll go to
narita yeah nrt you want to go to hnd if
you can yeah because you have to get a a
train for one naruto is not in tokyo
yeah
it's in chiba right yeah it's like
[ __ ]
further away from chiba isn't it yeah
also to get into tokyo will cost you
like 50 bucks yeah yeah oh it depends if
you go on the narrator express which is
like the most famous like bullet train s
thing from narita airport it's like it's
so expensive it's actually like 80 bucks
but there's a skyline as well which you
can get yes but like i didn't know about
that the first time i came to narita
because they don't advertise they don't
totally advertise their narrator express
because it's convenient yeah it's
because like the narita express um is
the big kind of
shinjuku right yeah it goes to shinjuku
right but uh yeah it's the it's the big
one that's advertised about how to get
into tokyo and like a one-way ticket
there uh using the narita express costs
about i think 80 to 100 bucks yeah [ __ ]
that
like 200 bucks yeah
the first few times i went to japan i
didn't i did not know that there were
other choices that you could make uh so
if if you have to fly to narita we
highly recommend the skyline yes which
is cheaper than the norwegian it's
cheaper and it stops it basically when
you get off your plane at narita are you
done go to the trains and they'll be
like a bunch of ticket things but
there'll be one specific office that
says skyliner yeah you can't miss it uh
they speak english as well so go there
yeah and ask them like 40 bucks yeah you
pay like half the price yeah yeah and
it's it's great and it's just as fast
it's actually just as fast which is why
i'm just like why is the narita express
twice as expensive because they can get
their money though yeah yeah but yeah go
to hannah hannah's super easy you're
basically in uh where are you near in
canada uh nearly odaiba yeah yeah yeah
yeah tokyo so you're actually one you're
in tokyo two you can you know take the
subway dude the [ __ ] uh you can take
the monorail dude the monorail is has a
sick view dude yeah the monorail awesome
or you can just get a cab if you're lazy
you can get a cab train or monorail but
the most aesthetic one is definitely a
lot of the caps have the uh
english-speaking uh computer thing in it
oh really yeah i've never used it i just
i just shouted them like go here
but um yeah this uh i've never seen them
maybe i should test it just see how it
goes yeah
yeah so like we said you know first
first step if you can fly to canada we
highly recommend you fly to hanada
because you're gonna have such
it's gonna you're gonna have like a way
better experience it's gonna be less
stressful getting just genuinely as well
that's a really nice airport yeah it's a
really nice airport you get better views
and it's also cheaper so
that's basically every reason you could
possibly think of to fly to a certain
airport over another if you have a
choice
it's normally more expensive to go there
but the cost of like the train tickets
and transitions yeah yeah it might make
up for my money
yeah exactly so it offsets the cost it's
like it's like gatwick in heathrow yeah
in london gatwick's a joke gatwick is
basically in brighton what's the [ __ ]
point of the airport it's great for me
it's it's annoying as [ __ ] it's
literally not in like in london what's
the other airport that you guys are
heathrow no there's one more right oh no
luton now no no no
then we go to like then we've got like
stansted
[ __ ] like i don't even count those as
like [ __ ] airports okay those getting
to stansted and stuff like that is more
difficult than get it like the journey
like to france yeah right right yeah
it's it's it's ridiculous about japan
we're talking about japan yeah pov
you've just landed in your airport where
where are you going to stay where would
you recommend staying what's it what's
the best player
[Laughter]
you've got a lot of options right like a
hotel is literally the same stories
don't do up okay but okay all right yes
you might have to deal with racist books
in your hotel room which sucks but it's
this it's like the same price as like a
capsule hotel
it's a closet because it is a capsule
hotel yeah i mean you get a bed though i
would highly recommend i would highly
recommend airbnbs airbnbs
is my is my best experience in terms of
accommodation staying in tokyo which
might be which might be difficult though
because of the recent like airbnb
even off because i have stayed in
airbnbs since they've got ridden got rid
of a lot of airbnbs and they are still
like 10 times better than most hotels in
tokyo and the reason is because most
hotels in tokyo are they are just
business hotels right they're they're
they come with the assumption that
you're just going to stay like
the guys staying there aren't even going
to be going to be in the hotel at all
unless you're staying at like a hilton
like everything else is just like yeah
everything else is just everything else
is just a closet or a shoebox i think
there's some decent ones i think i've
stayed in i don't know where they are
yeah priced i'm sure there is
i think you have to look you do yeah
yeah you do have to look but i feel like
with airbnbs there's just you tokyo is
absolutely saturated with hotels there's
a lot of hotels yeah like because they
know if all the airbnb yeah yeah you can
you can definitely find a good hotel if
that's what you want because i get it
sometimes you don't deal with an airbnb
because sometimes you know it's kind of
a weird experience you have to sometimes
really sometimes sometimes you get the
key in a really weird way and sometimes
you're in an apartment building and you
get stared at and stuff and then also
you're like the neighbor's house three
times
you don't really understand how the the
locks work and stuff you're like i get
it a hotel is just like boom card in
there's there's services they can do
your laundry and stuff i get it i just i
just feel like you it's yeah it's it's
it's not this it's up to you but like
i want to worry less about things i want
to safe in my room yeah but you're also
probably staying at a hilton
that's like that's like a one night
thing if i'm lucky
[Music]
you know i i feel like it's a waste
staying in a luxury hotel for like more
than one just like more than one day
because like you want to do [ __ ] like
you know what i mean like you want to go
outside like just get a hotel with
enough room where you can be comfortable
eating a cup noodle in it if you want
yeah
let let me try let me sell you on the
airbnb all right guys
okay because with airbnb you have more
anemies you have like you have a working
[ __ ] microwave or like one of those
like a lot of airbnbs have one of those
mini grills so if you want to like go to
family mart or 7-eleven or lawsons and
buy your buy the famous fried chicken
that's uh that connor and chris have
eaten a lot but you don't want it cold
you can perfectly just grill it in your
airbnb warm it's home when you buy it
what do you mean it's warm when you buy
it
how how long are you carrying around
this family i don't know i don't i'm not
okay so like
i i will say that probably the one
country on earth you don't need a
microwave is japan yeah there's
literally one on every corner that
you're allowed to use freely
that is true absolutely that is true
i love this one
i don't know how that was your first
lives
it's like guys they have a microwave
they have a microphone don't worry okay
okay but no like normally like i found
like you get more room in your airbnb as
well you like yeah like a lot of the
times the hotel rooms it's just a shoe
box where you don't have room to walk at
all
yeah with airbnbs you actually have
walking space sometimes you you have
like a living space and like a bedroom
space which is like which is good uh
another thing is that a lot of airbnbs i
found in japan especially they come with
portable wi-fi right so a lot of times
you don't want to faff around with
getting data in japan because it's like
it's such it's such a hassle but with so
many airbnbs basically about 90 of
airbnbs i've stayed at the owners are
kind enough to provide you with a
portable wi-fi which not only works as
the wi-fi in the airbnb but works as a
portable wi-fi which you can take with
you as you're traveling around japan
although i will say that i think most if
not all train stations in the tokyo area
have free wi-fi
uh
[ __ ] annoying to connect to it though
yeah
also also every mcdonald's has a free
wi-fi yeah i mean just honestly you get
it from the airport there's like a
bazillion of these it is expensive as
[ __ ] though data is expensive
google maps is literally your best
friend yeah i still use it with the
amount of walking you're going to do
with me yeah everyone's like if you have
like an international plan for data or
something i i highly recommend that
because
buying data here which is why i
recommend airbnbs if they give you
portable wi-fi buying data here as a
tourist is really really [ __ ]
expensive it's like seventy dollars for
like there's two weeks ago there's
vending machines
vending machines at the airport that do
sim cards
really do
data only sim cards yeah they are quite
pricey but you know it will do what you
need to do because i mean google chrome
you can get a vending machine experience
right off the bat right yeah
oh my god i've never bought a similar
vending machine
there's also you can
just like type in portable wi-fi
whatever airport you're going to
there'll be ones you can get as well
yeah well one piece of advice for me
that i want to tell people is get a
seeker
oh yeah oh yeah because that's going to
be your best friend as well this is this
is a suica card okay this is the
equivalent to an oyster card although i
don't believe we use it
like metro cards um it's really easy uh
because
you can get one at basically any machine
on the metro or anything like that here
like 500 yen yeah it's like it's like
500 yen and you can load it up
immediately um every machine has an
english option and multiple other
languages as well so you don't need to
worry about learning japanese to buy a
suiker car it's super easy and yeah same
with
bullet trains yeah and also you can pay
with it if you don't want to deal with
cash load up load up a [ __ ] ton of money
every single fast food chain and every
single conbini will accept it everything
mostly vending machines as well yeah
except machines trains yeah
everything which is which is very very
useful because if you don't
if you don't remember this then you're
gonna meet needing to bring cash do not
expect to be able to pay by card
anywhere just just some places do accept
it but don't expect to come into a place
even if it looks like a you know a big
establishment that should have a card
machine a lot of places don't accept
cards or even credit cards to be fair it
is getting better
like a lot more places now especially
like since when i first moved i
remembered like half the places i went
to didn't accept card at all but like i
feel nowadays like most places in
central tokyo except card but yeah also
you know it's the suka is good because
again you can use it not just at a
restaurant but literally anywhere yeah
um so super handy yeah but also just
carry cash with you always yeah because
you're going to need it for something in
japan um even if you don't know what it
is immediately there's always going to
be one little thing where this place
doesn't accept anything but cash or
machine doesn't accept anything but cash
you're you're going to need it so don't
don't assume that we're like in japan's
like every other you know first world
country where uh we have a character
like a mom mom-and-pop like shop right
like
like the old like restaurants and stuff
like that they'll usually just be like
nope cash only yeah yeah and uh i know
since you're watching trash taste you're
i'm i'm guessing a lot of you are weebs
right i'm guessing i'm guessing maybe
maybe i don't know this i don't know huh
where you going with this
do you would you could you talk about
archaeology we've told we've talked
about how akihabara is overrated right
yeah or how we think it is but i feel
like it still is
one of the best places to go if you just
have like a day or two in tokyo and
you've never been to japan before right
because i feel like there's nothing that
really beats that first day akihabara
experience because yes
yes you can get figures for a better
price online or other places what's the
magic it's the magic yeah it's the magic
right it's like it's like disneyland but
for weebs yeah it's the fact that
literally every billboard and building
you see around you is covered in anime
yeah which is like not really a place
you can experience anywhere else in the
world or rather anywhere else in japan
yeah exactly it's kind of out of the way
it's a little annoying to get there i'd
say i mean it's like what like 15
minutes from tokyo station
yeah i'd say if you're going to stay
anywhere stay around shinjuku shibuya
you want a fun time
yeah yeah yeah i'd say shinjuku probably
has the most stuff nearby yeah you have
like
shibuya yeah yeah all that kind of stuff
and then you have the akihabara side of
tokyo which you have to quite easily
yeah which you can just cut straight
across to has like you know asakusa you
know
like you can easily spend a day in
akihabara oh easy like easily
like every time i go to akihabara even
today i still find new [ __ ] to do yeah
exactly whether you like retro games
anime figures uh classic stuff you know
like really old transformer stuff
any kind of otaku stuff is that made
cafes
boys boys
don't go to a cafe don't go to
we
a
major
helping them yes go to a maid campaign
have you been normal caffeine absolutely
not yeah you don't want to no i can tell
people to go we've got we've gone to
like i can get an affiliate there are
okay here's here's the thing there are
way cooler themed bars in japan and in
akihabara than maid cafe you've been to
a bunch corner and like so many yeah
you've been to so many and like you know
you guys you guys have made videos about
it um sydney's making videos about it as
well like everyone wants to go to a maid
cafe but i feel like the maid cafe is
like the most basic themed cafe you
could possibly go to when there are
experience that i haven't had but i'm
okay not having i i can have it i've had
the experience and i have had a much
funner time going to like the other
themed bars because wouldn't made
caffeine
i feel like it's an afternoon thing it
is an afternoon thing but it's also it
doesn't matter it's just cringe yeah but
yeah like i hated it i just want to see
people go it's also why do you want to
see people go because i want to see
people yeah i want them to stay in
business right i don't know that they're
dying right they're dying at the moment
i want them to stay in business but i
don't want to be the one giving them
music
it's a cultural icon
it is a cultural icon but i feel just
give them your jokes
yeah i feel with the amount of like
other themed places in japan and japan
is very good at doing theme like bars
and restaurants and stuff like that yeah
i just feel like
maid cafes are kind of just becoming
like old at this point yeah because like
you know what to expect at a mei cafe
yeah but you don't know what to expect
at like i don't know like a lockdown a
lockout or you know any of those like
really cool you know kind of hidden
underground like bars and cafes right
it's lockout yeah a lockout is this
prison themed uh
restaurant that i've been to a few times
where is it uh there's a couple there is
one in shinjuku i believe oh i think i
went you basically go underground
through a haunted house and then you end
up and you eat inside of a cage that's
what they scream half the time yeah they
think i went through the show i think i
went there and i thought the food was
like the worst food i've ever had in my
life no the main cafe if it was a
million times no like i i i feel like
the maid cafe food i don't know why it's
just
a 100 of the time it's horrible food i
mean it's on par with
like you know rice
where
we only think it's good food because a
cute girl made it no no i don't know i
think it's okay no but most people feel
that way so well the cute girl made us a
must be good see and everything's
overpriced as well yeah you know it's
everything's overpriced and it's like 20
bucks for the most mid-autumn ice i've
ever had yeah yeah right
you know you get a good army rice though
i mean if you want like a brand one yeah
yeah roll host and then they do a good
one
there's one on akihabara this is like
the denny's like deluxe yeah it's like
so fancy and the prices are like
ridiculous this is this is what i feel
denny's wished it was
like like going to japan and just going
to a maid cafe with all the themed bars
that all cafes are available it's like
going to america to for a burger joint
and going to mcdonald's or some [ __ ]
like that you know that's right
that's that's like you like you can you
have to
you have i'm there you have so much
choice of so many different themes and
different unique concepts and then you
go to a maid cafe where they do the momo
beam on your food and call it a [ __ ]
day that's it that's it thank you thank
you for 50 dollars
and uh you know if uh there's there's a
lot more places than you can go to
through to a maid cafe also i want to
[ __ ] die when i go to a major just go
to me cafe at your local con it's
probably the same experience it actually
is actually honestly the same
it's honestly the same except the only
difference is that the one in japan you
probably won't understand what they're
saying half the time exactly that's the
only difference yeah all right but uh
yeah i mean you'll understand when
you're at all majors i don't want to get
hurt i want to go i'm far too british to
like i'm like i want to see you at a
main cafe you and you and chris and are
made careful you and chris and the main
cafe would be the best
that's too much cringe
yeah i mean i mean like i'm i even i'm
more attuned to like the anime culture
and stuff and i'm just like i can't
handle no i couldn't handle it it's
it's uh i i think i'd rather be seen at
a strip club or something like that i
would i i would
i feel like that's less normal yeah
more normal yeah more normal but yeah i
mean like obviously get akihabara out of
your system because you've got you're
going to go you're going to want to go
to akihabara yeah you are going to have
a good time yeah and uh if you're
looking for you know places to go then
just look at our figure special you know
that's that's we basically curated our
figure special to the places that we
like to shop in akihabara um are there
any other shops you would recommend in
akihabara that they go to oh god this is
so mean why why me
super potato is really good that's the
retro game place that's like what's the
dojin store oh it's an animal yeah yeah
yeah well there's one there's melon
books which are two different ones uh
both are good yeah that's melon books i
think has like four entire floors of
just doujin stuff so if you like that
then go for it but
has a better selection in my opinion
yeah i think so and that one has like
seven floors or something that is like
seven or eight floors
and there's two buildings as well yeah
yeah exactly
um yeah because like a lot of akihabara
is you go into a store and it looks like
a one it looks like it's just a
one-story store because it's like a
[ __ ] tiny right uh it's full of stuff
and then you go in and you realize they
have stairs and then you go up the
stairs and you realize there's another
set of stairs and you just you realize
that it just keeps going up and up and
up and up so a lot of suddenly you're in
a mob
basically and also like the best thing i
think about akihabara especially when
you go into like the really like small
building unmarked buildings is that each
of the floors is usually a different
store entirely so you could be in a
figure store at one point you go up the
stairs and then suddenly you're in an
idle shop and next moment you're in a
retro game shop yeah yeah exact moment
you're in a tech shop and it's all in
one building and it's yeah great yeah
that's why you can literally spend like
hours just in one random building that
you stumbled into
um and of course like the arcades there
as well because if you want to go to
japan i highly like you have to go to
the arcades there's this oh go to the
sega ones because they have the [ __ ]
mech pilot game dude yeah yeah what's
that one called i can't remember but
maybe don't go to the other ones in
north carolina though because like most
of them are gone yeah
all
there's a ton of sega buildings outside
of akihabara oh yeah yeah they have like
good games but the uh but the one in
zanacki happened have a lot of like
vintage games yeah they have typing of
the dead still they still have that yeah
they have a they have an entire building
that just has like an entire floor full
of like old school ladies crazy taxi
it's got a few other games got time
crisis two or three which one you play a
game on the arcades for like 50 yen i
think yeah yeah it's like really like
most most arcade games are just a
hundred yen which is
uh the
old uh retro game oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was dope as [ __ ]
which is also right shinjuku so yeah
yeah uh i can't remember what it's
called just type in arcade place takada
no baba yeah yeah um and yeah like i
still think like my favorite arcade game
is the mecca pilot game so there is have
we talked about it we've mentioned it
before but again we don't know the name
yeah it's literally like a hydraulic
mech
you'll see it because you literally are
piloting a mech right you'll see people
like [ __ ] tilting and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah so you it's kind of like
reminds me of um these old-school like
rides you see in malls or sometimes or
something where it's like you you're put
into like a capsule and you're like it's
like a roller coaster and like the uh
the capsule like tilts along with like
the roller coasters like 4d yeah like 4d
that you're seeing so imagine that
except you control the roller coaster
okay so when you when you when you pilot
this mech it'll tilt with you know it'll
tilt and curve uh when you accelerate
you feel like the acceleration and
everything it's
it's so cool it's if you're a mecca fan
or even if you're not it literally is
the closest you will ever come to
piloting a giant robot and it's pvp and
it's pvp as
well and it's also like a hundred yen
yeah yeah it's like it's like five
minutes ago yeah yeah it's really good
it's battle royale but uh if you are
gonna go to the arcade you probably
should look at like a tutorial about how
to get like the cards
because some of the progress some of
them no like some of the games they will
not let you go past the tutorial stage
if you don't have a card like basically
you you pay the money every rhythm game
yeah basically every rhythm game like if
you don't have a card um you're you're
basically just stuck at the tutorial
level there should be a card printer in
the building if it's a big arcade
yeah most of the bigger ones have it so
if you don't have a card just go to a
big one and there should be a machine
that prints cards and they all have
there's like three different ones though
you need to figure out which ones which
it's really confusing i'm sure there's a
guide online i'm sure yeah also if
you're having trouble what the [ __ ] is
being said on screen i just hold up
google translate to the screen and
generally it works yeah yeah actually
that is a good le that is a google
translate is it's not perfect but it'll
give you the gist of everything yeah it
will be your best friend but basically
you should use it yeah google translate
i didn't know this until i moved to
japan where google translates has a uh
camera option where it will live
translates things that you put through
the camera of google translate uh it's
been a life saver for me in a lot of
places here in japan
yeah exactly and uh if you ever in a
restaurant where it's all in japanese
then google translate camera will be
your best friend unless it's handwritten
and [ __ ] unless it's handwritten
uh and then you just got it blindly and
then you just gotta hope that you're
with joey and uh he'll translate
everything for you i just say
also sue me i asked for their
recommendations and i'm like rolling the
dice yeah please for the love of god to
give me something good when i usually
it's good probably normally it's
normally one time they gave me chicken
carpaccio that was interesting oh wow
raw chicken raw chicken raw chicken
chicken sashimi
yeah that was that was i was like damn
what a what a great recommendation
can't wait to get salmonella yeah
this episode is sponsored by athletic
greens you know it's the year of 2022
and uh i've put a lot of weight as many
of you have pointed out in the comments
section so this year i really wanted to
look after my weight and general health
and one product that has definitely
helped me with that personally is
athletic greens ag-1 by athletic greens
is an essentialist nutrition company
that has created a movement around
simplifying your health routine it's not
just for athletes it's for busy moms
dads rookies first timers and everyone
in between yes even anime youtubers
would you believe it athletic greens
contain 75 vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens in one convenient daily
serving this special blend of
ingredients helps your body's
nutritional needs and supports gut
health immunity energy recovery focus
and aging and taking athletic greens
every day is super simple you just take
one scoop of the powder eight ounces of
water once per day and that's it so if
you would like to get your body back
into shape like i am trying to do this
year then make sure to go check out
athletic greens down in the description
below and thank you delay greens for
sponsoring this episode back to the show
but i mean if you're into weave stuff
it's not all akihabara of course that's
like the big mainstream place i i
personally recommend for weeb stuff
that's not archibra
not gonna broadway i was gonna say
because i feel like with with akihabara
you get overwhelmed maybe that's what
you want maybe you want to be
overwhelmed with weeb stuff but the
problem with the problem with akihabara
is that it's very very much aligned with
let's say let's say weeb culture as
opposed to you know more other
underground anime culture which you can
you can find more
cool stuff in akihabara i i'd say i
don't know
more cool stuff in uh nakano broadway
because the way i the way i describe
akihabara is it's just like imagine if
you're on in on the convention floor
right that's that's basically akihabara
where you're on you're you're in the
dealers the dealers hall that's
akihabara uh nakano broadway is more
like the artist alley where you can get
more of like the
more more like
more stuff that's not my shops around
there like the unconventional stuff the
unconventional stuff right in knocking
on broadway you know there's a store on
the first floor where they just sell
nothing but old anime cells yeah yeah
that place is really dope and then
there's other ones that are like from
like 40s and 50s japan styled stuff and
everything huge store there if you like
retro games and you want gamecube games
or something that's really cheap there's
a place called book off oh yeah oh yeah
look off sells a lot of retro enhanced
stuff yeah i mean that's
yeah
so many dude i saw like super mario
sunshine in box for like 600 yen yeah so
like five bucks nice yeah book off is
like a uh it's like a big chain here
isn't it yeah you can you can find book
offs
in
most major places there is a book off
somewhere so if you want a good deal for
second-hand stuff just like a bunch of
them there's book-off which is mostly
focused on like books and games and
stuff like that and then there's another
one called the name's horrible but it's
called hard off
i didn't really think that one through
uh which is more like kind of like
second-hand like appliances and like you
can get you can games you can get games
at heart off as well yeah um but uh yeah
and then book off you can also buy like
secondhand clothes as well yeah this is
pretty good and then there's another one
there's another version of the off
series
yeah right off i don't know
yeah because like
like my big problem with akihabara isn't
just the fact that it's like
all anime which you know that's not
really that's not really an issue it's
just like you can't really find anything
else so
like if you want to go out for a nice
meal afterwards there's nothing really
around akihabara i think the only thing
i've had in akihabara is the royal host
and the the uh the ramen the raw ramen
or if you want a jason ramen to be fair
yeah well if you want like sorry guys no
no no i was about to say but what i love
about nakano is that nakano not only has
this like kind of cool underground like
especially in broadway the whole anime
and like weeb [ __ ] yeah but once you go
outside of the broadway section of
nakano which is just one building yeah
then it has some of the coolest bars and
restaurants restaurants and stuff i mean
the jojo bar is in nagano yeah exactly
so that's the perfect reason to go to
nakano that's that's a business i do
want to stay afloat come on outside
grinder yeah
the jojo bar is [ __ ] amazing yeah
that that's a place that we want to stay
in business not the maid cafes bring
your business to the jojo bar
on twitter though yeah yeah you have to
follow them on twitter
even though the google hours say
whatever he tweets out whether he's open
or not yeah because it's literally just
one person it's one dude yeah yeah so
yeah like like that's another reason to
go to nakano but aside from that there's
just so many other cool places and other
cool restaurants and bars that you can
go to in nakano and it's one of those
places where you can just stumble upon a
place you know you don't need to google
uh you don't need to do a mailing and
like google which one's like five star
or something it's one of those places
that you can just get lost in you just
like oh that place that place looks cool
everything's so tight knit yeah and like
so many tiny restaurants and uh and bars
and stuff like that yeah cause like i'm
like when i go on holiday right i'm not
the kind of person who is just like
planning out everything i don't have an
itinerary what i prefer is just going
into a cool area and just discovering
stuff for myself you know that's that's
the kind of traveler that i am and
yeah and uh
of course of course and uh nakano is
like one of the best areas for that i
agree i agree yeah yeah i wonder so
we've gone to akihabara what else is
something that like you might consider
you know i i think even though
you know we don't really go there that
often anymore because i feel like it's
very much uh you've got to do it while
you're here
do a table normally hold on just go
crazy for it to go to like a cheap
izakaya oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
everything it's like it's like x amount
remember how many times we went to like
kinokura
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah if you've got to go to a
kinokura if you like to drink i mean a
lot yeah yeah on a monday it's 100 yen
beers yeah yeah if
if there's two words you need to learn
in japan it's not none of this like
[ __ ] konichiwa
arigato [ __ ]
discussion yeah no no you don't need to
know that [ __ ] that [ __ ] or susame as
connor just said and nomihoudai which is
all you can drink which is which is the
only the the only two words you really
need right
or tabitha
yeah yeah
is food yeah or you can or you can eat
or you can drink i feel like you'll know
it's nomihoudai because it'll be very
bright and it'll have a number yeah yeah
it'll be like 2 000 and you'll see a
picture of a lot of drinks yeah it'll be
like 2 000 something or two if you see a
timer like 2 000 plus 60 something yeah
you're either about to hire a person for
uh illegal activities or you're going to
be having an all you can drink so
fun for all the family really yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah basically yeah just go
just go to an izakaya do you recommend
going to a chain one or yeah [ __ ] yeah
do you go to a kinokura did you yeah no
it's not english on the table yeah
that's true
like a torii or like any of those like
chains like although it's not like
the highest of quality in terms of food
but like i think if you're one like 20
yeah what's it called again
yeah
we're saying the food isn't that good
but i remember coming here
it's [ __ ] amazing compared to
probably where you're from
japan we we have been spoiled our food
tastes uh we've become food snobs
because i remember i remember the first
day that connor came to japan and i took
him to kinokura the moment he got off
the plane yeah and he was like it's a
hundred yen for a beer and i'm like yep
and he was like oh but it's like it's
probably like a cup right out comes a
[ __ ] like pint yeah this is the
greatest country in the world exactly
exactly yeah literally yeah no the food
the food the food is good i i forget i
forget because i've been living for so
long uh if you're traveling out of
england the food is like [ __ ] 10 out
of 10.
compare compared to anything you can get
in england this is just like a basic
guide obviously we've been in japan a
bunch you [ __ ] know this [ __ ] you do
whatever you want but this is for the
the boys and and girls out there who are
coming to japan first yeah
yeah
everywhere you go to have the most 10
out of 10 food because you will have the
most 10 out of 10 food and uh learn like
go go do karaoke just just go speaking
of nomi horde yeah speaking of nami hoda
you will definitely need to know that
word for karaoke because basically every
karaoke has nami hoda and i don't know
why you'd want to do karaoke so but
maybe you do maybe you have a great
singing voice i don't i need to be drunk
to sing okay it will probably be a bit
awkward because they don't have like any
english help yeah you're getting it just
yeah i mean you'll be fine i'm sure they
used to follow just yeah just say the
hold up the number of hours you want in
your hands yeah and then say nomihoudai
and they'll tell you a price and then
you just say yes and i feel there's like
a weird i guess like stereotype of like
this karaoke culture outside of japan
because i think when most people think
of karaoke they think of like open mic
like on a stage and stuff like that
which is like i'm not for that yeah i
think that's kind of cringe because i i
love it dude i love it what do you want
to do i don't know i can't i can't do it
i like tequila
i like singing in front of you know my
friends and people i know in a room
because that's fun like we can all hang
the reason the reason i'm not really a
fan of like the open mic karaoke
is because you only get two types of
people that do it
it's either one the [ __ ] amazing
singers who are basically auditioning
for x factor the next day or you just
get the piss heads who'd like who just
murder your ears
okay i am
alive there is no the thing is there is
no in between yeah you you either come
out getting a free concert or you come
out regretting the fact that you have
ears there is like no between never a
moment where like someone finishes
singing and you're like hey that was
okay
yeah i think i like gary there's karaoke
bars in japan where you can sing with
everyone else i love them they're so fun
because i remember everyone everyone
gets involved everyone in the bar like
gets hyped yeah but you can do that with
like a small crowd in a karaoke room
right but what if you just want to like
meet some random japanese people
those things oh yeah i mean but i feel
there's better ways to meet japanese
people than a [ __ ] open mind karaoke
no no it's the best way but like i
remember because i never really thought
about it because in my head karaoke was
always you know the the japanese style
character yeah like in a room right so
like i remember when uh when felix uh
came to japan and i really wanted to
take him to a karaoke in his head he was
like no i don't want to go to karaoke
why and he's like because he thought
about the open mic [ __ ] yeah and he's
like nah i don't want to do that and i'm
like oh my poor sweet innocent child you
don't know what real karaoke is like and
i took him connor was there
i went with uh dave as well from
boyinaband yeah and he was like that's
the most fun that he's ever had in japan
and like i [ __ ] told you yeah it's
it's honestly like one of the funnest
things you can do in japan i feel like
because
i think the thing about japanese karaoke
is that the song selection is [ __ ]
godly you want to sing anime songs of
course you want to sing anime songs you
have all the anime songs at your
disposal but if you can't speak the if
you can't sing the nihongo then uh you
got basically every major song from
england and yeah america tablet and
they'll be like foreign songs or
something yeah yeah you can speak like
uh korean songs and chinese songs as
well like like i i think i think the
japanese karaoke has a better selection
of english songs than english karaoke in
it's insane right yeah um yeah like it's
it's one of the funnest experiences you
can do with your mates oh you can also
get costumes oh yeah oh yeah we did that
when we first came to japan didn't we
you can go down to the first floor
you'll know it's karaoke building so
like something else cyberpunk outside
they always have the neon signs or the
really bright signs yeah it's massive if
you've seen the floors if you see neon
signs it's going to be pachinko or
karaoke and uh the inside looks like a
palace i saw this pachinko they all like
a palace inside yeah go into go into the
building if your ears are bleeding it's
probably a pachinko yeah
if it's not bleeding it's probably
karaoke yeah because karaoke is actually
soundproofing yeah
although all the pachinko buildings have
tinted windows so you can't see him yeah
so they're like frosted but you'll
you'll if you'll know it's a pachinko
building because when someone enters it
and the doors open you can hear that
[ __ ] from a mile away
yeah and like i feel like
do the karaokes if they want to sing uh
anime songs or japanese songs do they
have like a function in a lot of
karaokes now that where you can actually
when he actually spells it out not in
like katakana ah there's something
there's something
super rare and the selection is super
limited you're better off just like
looking up the english lyrics on your
phone that's true that's true that's
true but uh yeah but they have like tv
sizes where they actually play like the
visuals and stuff which is pretty dope
my favorite things is uh seeing what
kind of music videos they play with your
songs that you're saying during karaoke
because it's like karaoke videos are my
favorite
what is who films that who i'd like okay
i think it's the same people make the
bowling animations yeah probably
must be so like if you've never been to
like an asian karaoke a lot of the music
videos it's basically like the
equivalent of a stock a stock uh a stock
image
just with music videos right so you'll
have like this random i don't know my
favorite ones is where is the white guy
at the bar it's the one yeah yeah you
know the one i mean
he's just like a sad dude
it's like a sad specific reference
that'll be like one person it appears
like every four songs yeah oh it's like
every queen song is just like these five
people just dancing on a dance floor in
this empty bar and it looks like it's
the saddest [ __ ] party
yeah right
that's my favorite
yeah
and yeah i don't know what i don't know
what company
[ __ ] film this karaoke music video
british i think
that's the thing because it's not asian
people it's uh it's all like either
british or american yeah i see it's so
weird i actually that's a really
interesting topic i like i i would
actually want to know who actually who
actually filmed these where who made
these who actually made these ask joy
sound or something yeah maybe where are
these videos can i get yeah can i can
you link me to the video they look like
they're filmed in like the 90s yeah
they're really old because most of them
are still on like a four by three
aspects yeah yeah yeah yeah you best
yeah you know you've like picked like a
good song or a popular song they when
they have like the actual music video
you're like oh we're singing good today
boys we're singing the time when you're
selecting the song it says if it comes
with the actual music video yeah and if
it doesn't then you're gonna probably
get a white guy at a bar yeah cause the
saddest thing is when you select like a
banger song or something and you're like
i'm ready and then you hear like a midi
track and you're like
oh it's like like it has like a [ __ ]
banger like guitar riff or something and
it's just like it's like the worst
immediate sounding guitar ever it's like
me
that's fun but no karaoke is great
especially especially with your mates
and it's a great like it's because
it's a great way to just open up with
your mates because normally you go to a
karaoke bar and you don't really want to
sing because you don't want to embarrass
yourself in front of strangers but with
japanese karaoke you can just embarrass
yourself in front of your mates equally
yeah and uh it's a hell of a fun time
but if you want to embarrass yourself in
front of your mates in another way you
can also go to an onsen as well a public
golf yes which i think is a much taller
hurdle for a lot of people i'd recommend
just going to uh you know you can book
like uh ryokans uh which normally have
onsens uh you can book them on like
booking.com yeah and even if you have
tattoos like uh you know you can if you
do yeah if you have the expandable
income where would you recommend for
that though because before we we had the
massive onsen
uh in tokyo
yeah yeah onto monogatari unfortunately
we can't recommend that anymore because
that was because i was so sad i'm so sad
because that was like the perfect onsen
to recommend because you go to the onsen
solution
and then you'd go you'd go to like diver
city and just see the massive gundam and
you're like damn what a perfect day trip
yeah that's the perfect day trip
unfortunately that's not available
anymore i still think some of the well i
mean it depends how far out of tokyo you
want to go into i mean there's a lot of
like small bath houses in and around
tokyo and like the more uh like suburban
areas uh but that's not really an onsen
if you want like the onsen experience
without going too far out of tokyo i'd
say hakone is probably yeah
it's pretty good um that's in uh
kanagawa which is one prefecture across
but you can you can well not even you
can get these it's a romance car yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know
[Music]
it's like halfway between a bullet train
and a regular train it's like more
bougie than a regular train but it's not
as fast as a bullet train yeah and you
can go directly from uh shinjuku to
hakone in like an hour i think yeah
it's relatively cheap as well yeah
um and yeah it's a really really nice
little cute smile
yeah it's it's really cool it's got
there's this really small ava store um
right on the station yeah yeah which i
go to every time i don't know and the
reason for that is because hakone is uh
what they based tokyo three off of yep
um so if you've seen evangelion and
you've seen the movies uh you all
recognize the trains that like that that
they use there because they look exactly
like they do an ava um you'll be like oh
so i see shinji right there listening to
listen to your headphone oh look
disgusting
and you walk around you see vending
machines and like oscar and mari and
like gingers
if you want like a nice kind of maybe
like a two-day trip outside of uh tokyo
because hakuna is not only really good
especially you know if you love eva of
course but like also you know there's uh
the jio kudani which is like uh like the
sulphur plumes of like the mountains of
hakuna is really nice and there's never
been there before that's really dope you
go up this like huge uh like i was about
to say monorail it's not a monorail it's
like what do they call it like this uh
[ __ ] what are they called it's like not
a ski lift but what's what
gondola yeah gondola that's it yeah you
got this like gondola from the base uh
of this lake uh in in uh in hakone and
you go up into the mountains and you get
this really really nice view of the lake
and on a good day like if the weather's
really good you can see this like
perfect view of mount fuji as well so
that's really dope and then you go into
this uh little valley and you go into
this place called
which is called hells valley um japan
has a couple of hells valleys oh
as well um and there's also one around
like gifu as well right but um yeah it's
just this like really cool like sulphur
plume
place where you can get really close to
like volcanic sulfur plumes kind of
smells like farts uh the entire time
yeah i mean but it's kind of a really
cool unique experience um yeah i
personally recommend it's a good day
trip yeah because i really khaka was the
first hot springs town that i went to
and i really enjoyed myself the one
thing i will say is if you go to hakone
um it's really
it's really weird because like i went to
hakone and i expected it to be something
it's not similar to tokyo but like you
expect to go to a hot spring and then
you expect to like walk around and
explore somewhere but like a lot of
ryokans they expect you to stay at that
one establishment for the entirety of
your trip right a lot of a lot of these
hotels and a lot of these ryokans will
have all um
will have all everything you need within
that facility because they don't really
expect you to go out and explore because
normally there isn't really much to
explore in that immediate area unless
you take a bus or something right yeah
um at least that was that's my
experience so yeah there's like don't
expect like you can go explore but if
you want to go explore you probably need
to plan it out a bit more because the
place you're staying in
is isn't necessarily going to be near
a lot of tourist attractions yeah um
especially if you're staying at a ryokan
um having said that if you do stay in
the ryokan uh be prepared to uh get up
and eat [ __ ] breakfast okay
that's that's that's that's one thing
which uh at an egregiously early time i
i'm not sure if i am a fan of it but if
you do say ryokan very hands are great
right very kind of great because i feel
like in terms of hotels they're like the
most aesthetic place you can stay yeah
you are pampered there it's great it's
the most authentic like japanese
accommodation experience yeah exactly
and then you normally have the nicest
onsens that you could you could find you
normally sleep on a on a futon though on
the floor so not a bed so if that's
something you might but if you want that
authentic japanese experience
[Music]
yeah but like if you if you don't come
down for breakfast at the agreed time uh
they will find your family and they will
kill everyone you love or at least
that's what i get out of like if if
it's included in the cost as well so
yeah that's why they're normally quite
expensive because dinner is normally
included yeah they don't want you
wasting money yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
you know these dinners are normally like
really large courses they're like the
reason why already okay like you know
like real cons like normally like what
like three four hundred dollars a night
minimum
and that's because like half of that has
gone to the food if not food yeah you
will be eating like a king you will you
won't eat like so if you see the price
of the ryokan um don't get too shocked
at the price because you're paying for
the food as well and it's normally like
really really
really good food it's high quality it
might be even a bit too much sometimes
you'll get a good uh taste of the local
dishes though normally yeah these local
ingredients yeah and uh yeah a really
good way to just try japanese food that
you normally wouldn't order like i never
i'm never gonna order half the [ __ ] they
give me oh yeah yeah cause half of it is
super slimy yeah uh but i always eat it
because i don't wanna you know have to
make eye contact with that small
japanese lady who uh asked me why i
didn't like it which they have done many
times oh really yeah
so now i just i just i just eat
everything i i eat everything but
originally when i didn't like eat
something they would sometimes just
stare at me and be like why didn't you
eat it
what what's wrong
what's your dress
do you have covered are you dying i will
find you i will kill you
that's the thing you feel so intimidated
but no like it's like i i'd even like
recommend going to ryokan to try the
traditional japanese food over even
going to a restaurant right because with
the restaurant you don't know what to
order you know you don't you look at the
menu and it's like i don't know what i'm
going to like but it's kind of like
ryokan food is kind of like a tasting
menu you know you kind of get a little
bit of everything lots of little small
chunks of a lot of them
some things you don't like but it's a
great way to just easily
get the traditional japanese experience
um just don't miss breakfast because uh
did they did
did i hear you say like they came to
your room once and woke you up to get
breakfast oh yeah no yeah a woman
literally i was i was with chris
i think i was on a journey across japan
trip and one morning i got oh the night
prior i got very drunk uh so as you as
we do as you do and then the morning of
i was very hungover and uh you know and
the lady kept knocking on my door being
like breakfast ready and i'm like oh
yeah shut up shut up i have a throbbing
headache right now and then she [ __ ]
just walks in and just like rips the
sheet off me and i'm just like what are
you like what are you my mother like
yeah what the [ __ ] she was like making
sure you're alive and i was like you
[ __ ] all right
she ripped it off yeah well like all
like slowly like took it off it's even
worse that's like more creepy and i'm
like for one i'm freezing my ass off too
i have a throbbing headache three how
did you get in
what the [ __ ] i've never heard of them
that's an exception though that's
something else most places they'll just
like ring you up on the phone to make
sure
yeah like five more minutes mom five
more minutes
please don't like modern real cans if
you will that are more like they're like
they have beds like western yeah and
they're like way more modernized um in
hokkaido
well it's it's like it has it's weird
cause it'll have tatami mats oh but
it'll have a bed and it'll have oh i
know what yeah yeah those are usually
like more higher up though right yeah
but they're normally it's because i find
that the prices aren't different like
really the really traditional ones
sometimes cost more than the more
modernized ones because
they're they charge a [ __ ] ton for food
or maybe they have uh a lot of workers
that's one thing they have so many
workers every okay
insane they do but also sometimes the
service is nuts yeah they're like the
moment you turn up there's like four of
them greeting you they'll like take all
your bags right away and then oh my god
it's just like so intense i'm like jesus
christ what's happening sometimes it's a
bit too intense right because sometimes
you're just like okay i i i know you i
know you're wanting to make me feel
comfortable but you're making me feel a
little bit too comfortable now yeah i
said like three or four recently with
chris on the video and it was really
i remember i walked up to one and uh
as we were driving into the euro clown
there was like 10 employees
just like slowly bowed i was just like
bro i'm not the queen like literally you
feel like
you feel like royalty in the best way
yeah it's good there's a lot of
different price points and different
kind of uh
variations of onsens and yeah
monkeys oh yeah and that was amazing
because the whole town is an onsen town
which town is this it's called uh i
think there's two i think this one's
called yutanaka
yeah yeah the other one was um which is
famous for like having a big big onsen
pit that you can you can't go in it but
what's it called
crew something
yeah there's a couple of them and uh
yeah honestly it's a nag whereabouts is
it not gonna so you can
if you tokyo if you really want to you
can easily get the bullet train as well
uh
yeah that's like the top three onsen
cities or towns that was so good because
we stayed in london that was literally
like one foot away from the town center
really cool really really cool area yeah
the other top three i went to uh was
geronsen as well that's interesting
that's the one where chris and i uh
bathed in a thousand-year-old log
oh oh that one yeah that's that's a
thousand-year-old yeah there's a bath
made out of a thousand-year-old log and
those are actually really really nice
that's in ghetto when you guys book
onsense well i know that's not a problem
for you joe but do you go with the
english sites or do you go with
fucking.com super easily okay uh unless
it isn't on booking.com which is quite
rare actually yeah i've never really
seen anything that's normal it's all on
booking.com okay it's really weird i
like you'd think like super traditional
but nah dude you you can book it all on
booking.com yeah have they modernized
have they actually miners i've i've
never seen a real can that i wanted to
go to that wasn't on booking.com right i
don't know why there is some hotels on
booking.com yeah yeah which is really
weird
um but yeah i i said at a place one time
where like they didn't have the onsen
built in they had a hot tub so they
would fill the hot tub with onsen water
they brought in via truck
that's weird so is that really an onsen
it's an onsen if it has onsen water in
it okay yeah yeah okay which if you fill
a bathtub with an onsen water that's
technically
if i bring sea water in my bathtub is it
the sea it's the sea is it the c oh yeah
well there's no like there's no place
where you can go for the tm onsen you
know you know the word onsen just means
warm springs yeah yeah you can just get
it what makes it onsen is that it has
like the [ __ ] minerals yeah
and every single onsen has like the ph
sign and stuff that tells you what's
outside of it so they're really strict
on what can and can't be an onset
that's really strange legally speaking
yeah
but uh yeah highly recommend just
getting over your fear of getting naked
in front of your mouth or whatever and
is that a problem is that a problem i i
think yeah
yeah for a lot of people jojo fans uh
that's don't this does not apply yeah it
doesn't apply to you yeah because i
remember like there's been a couple of
my friends uh who just like refused to
go to an onsen just because they were
like uncomfortable with getting naked in
front of me or you know the the mates
and i'm just like looks out for the boys
like dicks out for the boys dude like
it's we all have them it's like who
cares you'll get over it in five minutes
you know it's a bonding experience it is
it is it is it's a morning experience
[ __ ] i love saunas dude yeah like i
don't know if that's like a white person
thing
i love saunas i like saunas i just can't
stain them for long i love it i love
getting in the ice cold water [ __ ] dude
i don't like that i don't i don't you do
the things that i hate yeah
dude
the onsen for me is the warm-up for the
the sauna
oh really yeah i'm i when it doesn't
have a sauna i get so sad but luckily in
japan now recently sauna's becoming like
a trend oh yeah for some reason yeah
people are obsessed with saunas and the
health benefits yeah there's a lot of
like dedicated sort of places in japan
yeah yeah i'm and my god do i love sauna
i love one dude it's very wide of you i
think that is very very white but like
um but yeah like i guess going back to
tokyo is there any other places or areas
in tokyo's that you that you like i know
it's like a massive tourist trap but
just go to golden gate it's fun golem is
good don't go into any bars where a
guy's telling you to go into a bar yeah
go into bars shinjuku there's a lot of
really cool places in shinjuku but
there's also a lot of sketch places in
shinjuku so yeah you really have to be
careful again if someone tells you to go
into a bar don't go don't go into a bar
that's just a rule of thumb uh there's a
bunch of really cool bars not in
not so between and sanchome sanchome
there's a ton of really cool bars and it
like behind the malls
yeah there's a bunch of really
uh tightly knit areas that have a [ __ ]
ton of nice bars and nearly all of them
i've been into are pretty damn good okay
yeah
yeah i think it's mostly when we think
of like sketch places in shinjuku it's
mostly like some parts of golden gai and
nichol
which is like the the gay bar district
um i've been to a a few gay bars in
nichole and they're really really fun
but the problem is a lot of places they
won't let you in unless you're going in
with someone who they already know yeah
it's true yeah also a lot of them i
don't think are very foreigner friendly
i know there's quite a lot actually oh
really there's quite a lot okay i've
seen i've when i went filming there and
i've been there a few few times there's
a lot of bars that are very very foreign
so if you want to experience gay bars in
japan and they are pretty dope at least
the ones i've been to yeah yeah i got a
new chairman i mean i think gay bars are
just pretty dope in general check out
the one that i went to
it's an anime any song gay bar and i
hate some gay bar so you know you know
that sounds fun as [ __ ] yeah oh yeah it
is all the details were just gay bars
are like some of the funnest bars you
can go to oh yeah i say this as someone
who grew up in brighton uh there was a
bunch of gay bars
everyone's just like so up for anything
and it's just like it's just it's it's
up for anything it runs out for i
also they're just a lot of fun
it's just a good vibe it's a really good
bonding experience if you want to like
talk to japanese people especially yeah
yeah yeah um daikon yama has a great
bunch of cool balls like that area
does have a bunch of cool bars but they
do get a bit costly oh they're very
expensive but they're super super cool
like there's like breweries and daikon
yamaha oh the brewing was really good i
don't think i've been to daikon yes you
have gone yeah i've been we've been to
the brewery which brewery is it again is
it the spring valley yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh that's like that
oh i thought that was their business
that area has like like every single bar
i've been to in the area is sick okay
yes i i do agree with that i went to the
cigar bar and died on yemen
okay okay every bar in the area i've
been to is just awesome i just i just
completely blanked on the area neymar
was just like that's close to ebbis yeah
you can walk from here because it's
awesome as well
yeah basically
is just south of shibuya yeah um it's
one stop away and i'd say that it's like
i actually prefer episode over
uh shibuya even though shibuya is like
the
the more famous place to go to because
to me shibuya is just way too crowded i
don't know yeah no i get that yeah like
there's also a lot of like really cool
places in shibuya if you know where
you're looking that's true uh you know a
lot of like shibuya's a lot like
yeah shibuya's a lot like shinjuku where
like it is like heavily like infested
with a lot of tourist traps but yeah but
also shibuya is so massive that yeah if
you go to like you know like uh [ __ ]
aoyama for example which is like the
area on the way towards harajuku like
that place has a lot of like really cool
like hidden stuff around as well which
and it's not really that far from
shibuya yeah i think like yeah one thing
i would definitely recommend if you're
going to like the big locations is to
like kind of try to venture out of the
center because there you you do tend to
find a lot of really cool hidden stuff
that isn't overpriced to [ __ ] yeah uh
and that applies to like most places in
tokyo yeah exactly what you guys think
of ikebukuro i really like ikebukuro
right well there's two sides two sides
okay there's two sides east side of
ikebukuro okay the west side is like
very very very sketchy yeah yeah
the east is sunshine city and everything
around that area is actually a city and
uh and ultimate road yeah yeah all that
all that heritage what i like about
ikebukuro is that you get a little bit
of everything you know it's it's it it
is kind of like you said that was so me
me a little bit of everything a little
bit of everything everybody you do kind
of get a little bit of everything yeah
if you just want to like go to an area
and just you want to get some anime
you've got oitamo
yeah you've got some really really good
restaurants and really really good bars
you've got sunshine city
um yeah and then if you want a lot of
like really good like southeast asian
restaurants and like indian restaurants
you go to the west side of ikebukuro but
it's also very scary at the west side
yeah literally like i don't know what
happened okay yeah like the other side
is like literally just like
lots of sketchy places yeah to explain
you it you east side and west side um
you're not going to be able to easily
wander from one side to the other
because it's literally east side and
west side of the station so you
literally have to go through the station
to get to either side right
um and it's it's like
it's such a big dichotomy that i don't
like it's literally a [ __ ] line that
separates one like
the bougie side from like the really
really scat side and like i don't i
don't know how like one station can
separate like two areas that are just uh
the complete opposite of each other it's
crazy on the train on the one side it's
like oh you can eat oh all this and the
other side it's like women 500 yen an
hour yeah [ __ ] sex sex
there's a lot of people and like uh and
like uh host clubs and stuff like that
there's gonna be a lot of guys trying to
get you into a lot of girls bars yeah i
understand that you're saying you have a
[ __ ] yeah yeah each side's good you
got a round one a really big round one
very big round one yeah um and sometimes
shitty is a ton of malls yeah
yeah really good shopping really good
food uh lots of fun
around what round one is americans are
not around modest it's an american
as well i think so yeah they're round
one it's arcade plus uh bowling bowling
plus uh
[ __ ] it's got everything yeah i'm pretty
sure you can live in that round why
aren't you yeah yeah right it's good
it's got fun what was the place that we
filmed a video about joey um oh the
break room the break room was that nico
yeah that's an easter girl as well
that's an easy kabuki that's actually
like i want to go back there too i want
to go back
to another video yeah yeah so if you've
seen the joey uh joey's video with me
and him during the break room uh where
you get to just break a bunch of [ __ ]
they'd have more than that there as well
they have like axe throwing they have
axe throwing there
and uh what is it
actually yeah the axe starting there's
like a paint area as well yeah where you
can like spray paint or yeah you know
just uh that's a really cool place
and you can drink there as well it's got
a lot of like games there as well you
should also go to uh baggers i love bags
just type in b-a-g-u-s into google
whenever you're here and i guarantee
there'll be one within a walking
distance of you if you're in tokyo yeah
and you can play uh there's a variety of
things the three staples they have are
ping pong uh pool
and uh i actually recently filmed a
video at the ikebukuro baggage which i
hope it's out by the time this episode
sounds like the grand one yeah it's the
big one on sunshine road
yeah you can do golf ping pong pool
darts and i think that one in ikebukuro
has the largest selection of manga oh
okay and they also have like uh they
also have like a theater rooms as well
oh and you can just like if you like
rent out movies uh from outside of
baggage you can't do it inside the base
but if you go to like a rental place you
can bring in like games and like rental
games and like rental movies you can
just like have a room to yourselves play
games also the darts in japan is not
it's no basic darts this is like
cyberpunk darts
like it's like the board is like a score
there's animations and [ __ ] this thing
is so fun you gotta go yeah yeah also
you know ordering drinks is kind of can
be kind of stressful if you don't know
any japanese uh basically there'll be a
phone next to your table a lot of these
places
now they just have tablets do they
bangersters yeah i went in the bags the
other day you had to call oh really some
of them you have to call it some of them
have to call it you call up you just say
the name of the drink you want and then
say
ichi or knee yeah just just say three
phases uh the third the third the third
phase uh phrase sorry is a number
which is just like you just say numbers
or just number yeah which just means
like the beer on tap or the draft beer
or the craft beer default beer um that's
just basically the only drink i ordered
when i came to japan for the first time
japanese very drinkable i'd say i
wouldn't i wouldn't say it's the nicest
but just very easy it goes down
it's the thing about japanese beer is
that it's just very it's
it's it's kind of like
refreshing you know what i mean because
i was going to say it's like water but
it's that's that's not doing it justice
you know it's just very you know it's
not it's not american beer yeah it's
it's not it's like middle of light
necessarily it's not it's no middle like
watery it's just refreshing you know
because you could it's very light
without being without feeling like it's
a very cheap beer how do i yeah it's
like it goes down really light but you
still get the full taste of the beef
yeah yeah exactly i don't know how they
do it's like some japanese wizardry
happening but yeah like some of the most
refreshing beer i've had is
i guess this is a place that i also
highly recommend we're going outside
we're going way outside of tokyo now
is in hokkaido uh because how do you get
to hokkaido where do i stay in hokkaido
where do you stay in hokkaido well i've
only stayed near sapporo actually
but there are several ways to get to
hokkaido because hokkaido is uh hokkaido
is pretty pretty damn big by the way is
the big island at the top you should you
should go there because the food is the
best and the drink is the best part
you know you can get there by train but
it's pain in the ass from tokyo yeah
it's like four well i mean it's like
four or five hours and you the last stop
is in hakodate which is oh yeah now
just fly look actually like it's i think
like when i was stuck in hokkaido the
price for the planes was actually
cheaper than the price with this
like we're talking like if you want to
explore outside of tokyo maybe this is
your second or you know second trip
third trip you've used or maybe you're
just such an adventurer you may want to
go out or maybe yeah exactly maybe your
adventure you want to go out [ __ ]
highly recommend hokkaido oh yeah
sapporo is such a cool [ __ ] city it
is it is bars yeah go and get uh
something called genghis khan
[ __ ] awesome dude it's all you can
eat normally sometimes if you're lucky
uh yeah lamb
it's like korean barbecue with lamb but
it's a million times so because like
you're gonna come home you're gonna come
to japan uh and you're gonna cream your
pants at how [ __ ] good the food is
here and you're like my god this is like
peak cuisine how can it get better they
can't get better and then you go to
hokkaido and you're like
how they improved on perfection and then
hokkaido is like hold my sapporo yeah
yeah i'll give you good food yeah like i
don't know how hokkaido has just like
made like such good food even better
because all of the best japanese cuisine
i've had has basically come from
hokkaido it's just in hokkaido like the
best ramen i've had his is in sapporo um
if you want to seafood i've had it since
yeah of course the best secret i've had
is in sapporo uh if you want to go if
you're in sapporo and you want a good
just easily find like a ramen joint just
go to ramen alley um because there's
just a bunch of like different ramen
shops there and
up in
where i've had the best ramen i've ever
had in japan just like and like every
every every store there has like a
different type of ramen
um and it's just they are all [ __ ]
amazing they're all [ __ ] bomb
um
yeah just like hokkaido in general i
think if you're gonna go i i we do
recommend the winter at least i
recommend the winter um because there's
a bunch of snow there looks aesthetic as
[ __ ] winter wonderland yeah it is winter
wonderland that's where the snow
festival was held your plane might get
delayed
that is it forgot that is the one
downside of going to hokkaido uh which
is because it snows a lot you're kind of
playing gacha with your plane like will
you will your plane take off in time
will it not will it get cancelled well
the entire airport shut down uh yeah the
fight find out find out when you
basically go because you can never
really plan around that unfortunately so
you can go to nissiko which is in my
opinion one of the best ski resorts in
japan
just where we went it's [ __ ] great is
amazing yeah it'll probably be rammed
with tourists oh yeah
i mean it's amazing though yeah really
good food i mean like i feel like i've
only been on two ski resorts now in
japan and nisiko is the superior one but
also it is very foreigner friendly yes
so much so that you might have you might
encounter more foreigners than you will
japanese people yeah it's it's all
aussies yeah it's all aussies it it is
all
but then again that's that's almost all
ski resorts in japan it's just all right
aussies
it's good though really good area really
really really good i've never been to
hakadate though what's that like i
thought it was chill without this chill
i like it the best crab in my life there
yeah i think if you want the best
seafood
because really yeah because it's a pool
because that's where they catch all the
seafood oh okay so they have a little
fish market in hakodate which is the
fish market you go there super early in
the morning and you get literally the
catch that they caught a couple of hours
prior
and it is amazing in my opinion the best
[ __ ] seafood i've had yeah i think
even though seafood is amazing in
hokkaido yeah i have to say and how
about that it was like it was the best
next level right so good so it's also
really small like kind of quaint little
town as well um you can get around very
easily with like the tram system that
they have yeah um that's what that's
what we do you can walk a lot around a
lot of them center though you can you
can but you can also go to like kind of
the nearby uh mountains as well and get
like a really nice view of huckled out
there during the night um yeah really
nice would you reckon guy where do
record people should get the seafood
does any restaurants or do you want to
do honestly yeah yeah i mean even it's
all decent yeah even like the hundred
yen sushi places uh
really
yeah because the thing is like even if
you go to a big chain especially like
the conveyor belt sushis
um
because
because the uh obviously the ingredients
are locally sourced like just because
even if you go to the same sushi chain
that you might have been to in tokyo it
will taste entirely different to another
sushi to the same sushi chain that you
have in you know in another place
yeah so like even if you go to like a
conveyor belt sushi uh don't expect that
it was taste exactly the same in tokyo
as it will in another place you go to
because i've had the ex i've had that
exact experience where i'm just like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't realize that
the quality could differ this much with
the same chain oh yeah you think you go
to mcdonald's you you get like most of
the time get the same experience every
time but yeah with sushi chains it's
just you it's wildly different depending
no well not wildly because every the
baseline is good right yeah the baseline
is good it it goes it goes from good to
[ __ ] incredible yeah it's what i'm
trying to say here i've never had food
poisoning from fish here it's always
been sausages so
take that as scientific 100 percent
proof yeah
it's not even chicken sashimi or it's
chicken it's the goddamn sausage no
yeah i think i've like one
uh one thing you don't you need to take
an account into account is that it's
actually like it's a lot harder than you
think to get from hakadate to sapporo if
you want to explore all of hokkaido oh
it's right i'd say it's practically
impossible to explore all of hokkaido
because it's just so massive those two
well those two are like big major cities
without a car yeah
i mean i i i drove around hokkaido a bit
it's really fun i really recommend it
some really cool towns like toyota it's
really cool was really nice yeah like
the best supercar i've ever had in my
life it's in toyota so good yeah because
like the i think i think the drive
between hakadate and
sapporo is like four hours or something
three to four hours three to four hours
even with the train and we do two hours
with europe and most of the time it's
just you're going through the mountains
yeah which is really weird because like
it
you you can really get tricked by the
map right because you you go on google
maps and you go tokyo to hakadate which
is like which is like that and it's like
three hours or four hours with the
shinkansen and then
by the way huh that's not enough it's
not shinkansen the shinkansen stops at
hakodate oh okay okay no no no yeah yeah
yeah two two hakadate it stops a hakka
data right so it's like three hours so
it's like oh okay that's not too bad and
then uh you you're like okay maybe i can
explore sapporo as well because it's
just over just here it's just right next
to hakadate and then you google hakadate
to sapporo and it's like four hours four
and a half hours yeah to get like to get
like that distance and you're like what
how does this make sense so uh yeah
that's something to keep in mind which
is uh it's a lot harder to explore all
of hokkaido than it may initially seem i
think it's because when you're on the
mainland japan you're so used to like
everything being so much smaller like
all the prefectures are way smaller all
the the towns are more likely they're
definitely easy to get to easily to get
to easier and then you realize that
hokkaido in terms of prefectures is like
so much insanely larger than the next
biggest prefecture in japan that you
kind of forget that like oh yeah this
place is
[ __ ] massive
right it's like impossible to get around
yeah yeah are there any any other places
outside of tokyo that's the obvious
count
oh yeah are we gonna are we gonna talk
about kyoto and we are really nervous
what is it like cancelled
i don't know if we can mention it man
after that
i think
is still great to go if you're you're
going to go to osaka right because it's
a fun place yeah and you me
might want to go to usj see the mario
world yeah you may as well go to kyoto
it's it's an hour away 40 minutes i
think right no it's like super duper 30
minutes yeah yeah you may as well go to
both uh kyoto is a [ __ ] nightmare to
get around though i will say uh
i know there's ways you can get around
with public transport but honestly if
you're going there for a trip i'd say
just just taxi it around kyoto it's
super yeah so it's a lot cheaper to get
a taxi in kyoto and you can do way more
[ __ ] because if you just taxi from
places in kyoto you'll get so much more
done
i know that me and chris had like so
many like major like tourist things in
that one day yeah just because we just
taxied everywhere yeah and did it
yeah and uh the ryokans in uh kyoto are
amazing obviously super traditional if
you want that like super traditional
japan you're really good
you know
like all those and then the good thing
is again osaka is only 30 minutes away
nara where you can feed the deers is
only like 45 minutes away you can go to
the other side you can go to shiga which
is near like uh biwaku which is japan's
biggest inland lake that place is really
lovely
feels like underrated
iphone store of japan so everything is
so minimal and clean yeah kyoto is so
impeccable how do you think it's going
to be when the country opens up and we
get tourists i'm scared i've only ever
been to kyoto with no tourists yeah
because i've been to kyoto with tourists
and it's hell because like the reason i
was just like do we want to talk about
kyoto is just because like
yeah i mean like people people will want
to go obviously but it is
even more probably like when tourists
when the country opens back up it's
going to be even more of a tourist trap
than tokyo is
i think that's what it seems like
is extremely popular with chinese
tourists yeah because uh he's a lot of
historians i went during chinese new
year and it was oh my god oh my god it
was like literal shoulder
yeah because like kyoto yeah it's a cool
place it's not like the place that i
it's not my vibe when it comes to travel
just because it's like it's going to be
so busy so packed and you're going to be
lining up for like uh for like the
[ __ ] 10th temple that you've seen
that day or something like that and i'm
just like you know what maybe like maybe
we can skip this temple i just i i i go
somewhere i just want some nice food i
get it it's not for everyone but i love
it a lot of people love it um yeah like
i recommend the places around kyoto more
than kyoto itself kyoto is like a good
base hub i've been together a few times
in the past two years i gotta say my
enjoyment of kyoto depended on the
weather
right kyoto gets so hot it does in the
summer it's unbearable yeah i just i
wouldn't even bother going to oh my god
in summer i just i genuinely i tell
people i'm like just don't don't come in
august you're not gonna have fun yeah
just
come
between
october just come just come just come
come right now come throughs you want to
come
come between october and
april
i would mostly agree with you except of
the existence of okinawa okay if you're
gonna occur but how many people are
going to get okinawa like not that many
a lot of people okay
here's here's here's the thing because
that's where i recommend tokyo sucks in
the summer
i will fully agree with conor because if
you're going to go to japan to go to
just okinawa then [ __ ] go to
southeast asian countries like there's
so many [ __ ] beaches there you know
okinawa is where
we go when we live in japan because we
don't have [ __ ] off our we colonize this
island bizarre
yeah i mean okinawa is where
is uh is where we go if you live in
japan to get to like a good beach
because there's not many choices when it
comes to good beaches here in japan
unfortunately god forbid mainland japan
is a good beach yeah because i'm in like
shimoda and stuff
i mean
it has a bunch i don't know my standard
of beaches is very high yeah oh yeah
yeah so i don't know and i feel okinawa
is the only place that fits my
australian standard
i was raised in like some of the best
beaches in the world
yeah japan doesn't have a lot of choices
when it comes to beaches uh funny for an
island nation but then again i'm from
england as well and we have the exact
same problem so
i i would argue that okinawa is not only
great for the beaches but you know kind
of very similar to hokkaido where like
the food that you can get in okinawa is
like next level i've never actually been
to okinawa yes
but i've only seen like the spam sushi
you know like spam sushi is like you
know more famous one but like there's so
many there's so many like traditionalist
okinawan uku style foods that are just
so good and i mean like the booze in
okinawa as well like you know because
like in in a hokkaido you have sapporo
bee yeah right which is like you drink
saparabhi in hokkaido it's like poor
classic support class which you can only
get in like hokkaido for some reason
yeah whereas in okinawa there's a
specific type of beer called an orion b
or an orion b however you want to
pronounce it and orion b in sapporo
in okinawa is probably just as not
worthy as a sapporo in hokkaido you said
onion beer
and then you cut the onion cut the
onions
or it's spelled orion but it's
pronounced
orion beer is it's it's like a okinawa
specific beer and that on like a summer
day in okinawa is
god tea okay it's so good and just
okinawan food in general if you want
like a different kind of twist on
japanese food that you can't really get
anywhere else i would definitely
recommend okinawan food yeah and there's
plenty of okinawa based restaurants in
tokyo as well like there's there's a
really good one in nikki actually in
sunshine city i go to quite a bit
um so if you want like a different take
on japanese food i recommend knocking on
food yeah i mean i mean speaking of food
um a lot of people come here or at least
a lot of anime come anime fans come here
expecting to uh enjoy like the weeb
aspect and then pretty much everyone i
talk to they come to japan and they're
just like i stay for the food oh yes the
food collection
yeah yeah yeah right right you spend
your money on food if you're gonna spend
your money on something i i know it's
going to be hard walking through
akihabara and you can see some cool
anime figures spend your money on a good
meal you will not [ __ ] regret it
it'll be the best meal you've probably
had in your entire life yeah what kind
of things you guys recommend people try
out when they're here not ichiran not
each one right
now no no no
go to a job go to
wherever you are
find the filthiest grossest looking
ramen place most likely the ramen will
be a ten out of ten yes or one i mean
it's you know no it's always no no it's
never a one it's never a one the ones
that
the ones that have the [ __ ] neon
signs look really pretty on the outside
they're just covering the fact that the
food is made yeah and the thing is it
might look intimidating because
obviously it looks very traditional you
don't know how to order most of the time
it there will be a machine right
like a ticket machine and all you have
to do is put your money in and uh if
you're having trouble you know
figuring out
uh what the orders are because there's
normally like only like four ramens to
choose from anyway so that's the good
places yeah those are the good places
the less choice you have on the menu the
more like the better chance it's going
to be that it's gonna [ __ ] bomb
because it's like it's
uh because that that means that this
family or the the person running the
restaurant has just like perfected their
christmas they've perfected it they've
sharpened their craft you know
yeah um but most of the time you're only
gonna have like three or four ramens to
pick from you can like use the [ __ ]
google translate thing uh
hack that uh
life hack that we use um if you're
having trouble but it's not it's really
not that um intimidating at all so you
just choose you choose your meal maybe
you go with the gyoza as well maybe
you're doing beer with it um and then
you just give your tickets to the ramen
guy and he'll give you your order that's
pretty much it and it's the bit and it's
probably the best [ __ ] ramen you'll
ever have in your life yeah honestly uh
like we just said earlier convey about
sushi i actually prefer conveyor belt
sushi a lot of the times to the more
expensive sushi chains and sushi
restaurants i think i think it depends
for me like i i don't mind going to the
more expensive ones maybe like once or
twice a year but if i just want like a
consistently like good
sushi then yeah there's nothing wrong
because there's a lot of places that
they're just like lunch sets that are
like 2 000 yen you get like a bunch of
stuff that's true because you're like
right in front of you here's the reason
why like because with conveyor belt
sushi like it's
such a good value for money yeah and i
remember the first time coming to japan
and just thinking like the sushi is
amazing because it [ __ ] is amazing i
wanted to stuff myself full with as much
sushi as i could eat and you can't do
that with expensive changes i prefer the
ones with the conveyor belts but you
order and then it comes out on the
conveyor belt because that's most places
now yeah yeah i know there are still
some that have like the rotating ones oh
yeah yeah it's just like i would rather
have the freshly prepared one yeah
yeah so with a lot of conveyor belt
brands or places that we that you go to
um they'll have a system where some of
them some of them will literally like be
automated where they'll have a plate
that gets like shot to you on like a
[ __ ] and yeah the first thing is
usually yeah it's usually shaped like a
bullet train yeah yeah yeah right it's
like so thematically
it's so cool it's so cool and uh yeah
like i to this day i still
i still eat as much conveyable sushi as
i can because i think it's [ __ ]
amazing i love i love stuffing myself
forward sushi and i can't do that at
more expensive restaurants i mean
sushi's good sushi's good but at the end
of the day it's just fish rice wasabi
right it's fish fries from wasabi and
there's i also think you should try the
foreign food here like try to see what
their takes are on uh foreign foods it's
quite interesting they do some really
good foreign food here yeah yeah yeah
yeah
italian food especially time food's
really good here yeah there's some good
really good burgers different from
uh italian food in europe it's really
good though like imagine that you know
that some some restaurants combine the
techniques of uh you know
italian chefs but use japanese
ingredients which uh is can be really
[ __ ] impressive
uh it's maybe not the most authentic
thing but you get something new
especially the fish here yeah yeah oh my
god fish dishes in japan and italian
food are like next [ __ ] levels yeah
definitely holy [ __ ] the best kind of
fusion oh so good what do you think
about them trying wagyu beef
yeah try it try it i mean you know
the thing is there's so many different
types of wagons when you've lived here
long enough i feel like you you kind of
go off wag you yeah you're like i kind
of want more meat than fat yeah but the
first time you have it it's like a like
a [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] this is an
explosion in your mouth
of that flavor it's food wars it's based
on like yeah pretty much yeah eating
wagyu his mouth is just
like where's like the best place to get
wagyu if you don't know what you're
looking for though
that's really hard yeah go anywhere in
kobe i guess and just get kobe beef
there well let's let's let's assume like
every single prefecture in japan like we
have our own beef that is good i think i
think i think
in takayama is probably the best like
type of wagyu i've had right
kobe beef is like
it's good but it's so fatty at times
where you're just like oh my god i don't
know if i'm eating like a piece of fat
or not yeah you're just eating butter
basically yeah basically you just
americans you love them you'd love that
right yeah americans love it like saying
like teppanyaki you always get like you
can always get like wagyu
yeah tampon yaki's pretty good it also
just depends on how it's prepared as
well a lot of times but like what i
really like about like hidaku for
example is that like they literally just
like put a bunch like cubes over
basically just on a stick put it on top
of a fire just put some salt and pepper
on that [ __ ] and boom it's like the
best [ __ ] food you'll ever have and
they sell it as street food i mean
chris's favorite food yakitori as well
yakitori is good
again like
kind of wrong did you feel like the best
types of yakitori are the
all-you-can-eat ones or do you think
they should go to like a more
traditional yakitori place i think both
are pretty good i think if it's the
first time you're experiencing that
you're probably not going to be able to
taste the difference i think the only
ones who are like you know go only opt
to go to like say the more
traditionalist ones yeah the ones who
have just had so much [ __ ] tori
kizoku that they're just like all right
let me just try and be you know
if you really want to try those kind of
place though you really need to do need
to learn the names though yes yes
because a lot of those places don't have
a menu
oh yeah that's true because they just
you just walk up it's literally just a
counter and a dude standing there just
infinitely cooking chicken and you just
have to say that just saying that's the
best one is the best one
the layers dude they taste so good japan
does nikki based food so well oh dude
it's so good yeah it's really really
good i can just plow down on like 50
like negatives yeah i just i guess
chris always wants the sugar i think
soukiness just i love
the meatballs yeah
i love it i love it like why bastardize
this this chicken dude just give me the
bastardize the chicken rip it apart and
shove it back together talking about it
just grind it apart and make it into a
ball that's great it's just like it's
not the only time i will accept boneless
chicken
[ __ ] ground chicken the reason why i
don't like it
it's almost like
like negimo is the perfect balance
between meat and veg right you get one
bite of chicken and veg right yeah
perfect soup in it just pure like just
ground meat and i'm like this is too
much but like i like that because it's
it more evenly spreads the seasoning
right because it's it's seasoned in the
ground meat right
i mean i i just i kind of want a
variation you know
well you know that's the great thing
about yakitori right different
structures yeah
calorific ones there's like ones where
we like it's uh
meat filled with cheese pork belly i i
highly recommend pork belly as well if
uh
yeah
um yeah i mean that's the like again you
that's what i order if i don't want to
have something like wagyu beef but you
still want that like explosion of like
flavor
in your mouth like that perfect
what would you say then is the most
underrated japanese food for people to
try when it comes to japan right because
like everyone obviously everyone knows
that they're going to go to a sushi
place they're going to go to like an
izakaya but like
uh the one that no one ever talks about
unani niki's like the boss dude i was
gonna say unagi as well yeah yeah please
try unagi it is expensive it is
expensive it is expensive but it's worth
it
it's an experience okay because like i
remember i remember
explaining to my mom how i'm like really
into unagi but i had to explain to her
that uh it's uh eel right yeah she's
like oh yeah people why'd you like eat
well that's disgusting and that's
because like her perception of eating
eel is like jellied eels oh yeah i'm
just like my god like the living in the
uk has to like ruined your perception of
this [ __ ] s-tier food so it's like
the way it's prepared is that it's
grilled and then it's like smoked i
think as well yes yeah and so it's it
doesn't it's not slimy it's just like
kind of like you know when you grill a
fish and it's kind of like nice and
crumbly and dry and and then they s the
way they season and sauce this bad boy
it's not tried that's the thing it's not
somehow moist it's it's moist it's good
it's just like it has like the uh
consistency of like fish and it's like a
perfectly a perfectly good
uh perfectly good like flavorful moist
fish you put that on a bed of rice i i
feel like i feel like
there's some really cheap places you can
get it but i'd say the places that cost
around two to three thousand yen for a
box are probably like the places where
you'll get some really good ones yeah
you know i've gone to places where they
charged like seven thousand yen seventy
bucks which i've got a place where it's
like a hundred bucks for yeah and it's
like it's like damn it's good can you
tell the difference in the taste though
yeah i so i
it's weird man within an aggie it's like
i feel like the the subtleness of the
flavors especially the fish yeah when
you get it cheap it's so harsh the
flavor yeah yeah whereas like the good
ones the sauce is kind of light the fish
that's like the eel is just really i
don't know how to describe it [ __ ] it
i don't know do you know what i mean i i
know exactly i know you
i don't know it kind of like the skin
also the texture of the skin on the
cheek places is like really
uh rough yeah rough and kind of yeah
it makes you feel like you're eating
something fishy whereas normally when
it's good or naggy it doesn't remind you
it doesn't feel like you're eating fish
yeah it feels like you're eating meat
yeah which is like the weirdest
comparison yeah it's it's like a meaty
fishy kind of it's like it's like a meat
and fish combo yeah the best way imagine
yeah yeah yeah you have to try do you
ever get like ubereats unagi i've had it
a bunch uh it's generally at meh yeah
i'd say you've got to go to a restaurant
if you're in japan you're probably not
getting ubereats so don't worry about it
don't waste your time with uber i will
say sometimes that if it's a nice unagi
place you might have to reserve
unanimity takes a while to cook yeah
it's like uh a lot of places especially
if you're out there summer summer yes
it's a summer food
primarily but you can get in winter it's
still good yeah the places in the
countryside outside of tokyo normally
always have to call in advance yeah and
tell them that you're coming or that you
want to book because it takes i think at
least an hour or two to cook it yeah
though because it's smoked and stuff so
it takes a while it's really really good
really really recommend it yeah and
people don't really talk about it
because people don't like the idea of
eels
yeah i'm always hyping it up though i
love it yeah i mean i guess for me if i
can't say unagi uh if you are going to
like a more expensive uh seafood place i
really like uni i mean yeah
i know connor i know connor hates it
but i've uni has like really grown on me
since i've moved to japan like really
really yeah i just like okay you know
how favorite you know how you know they
say like if you if you take a seashell
with you and you put your ear against it
then you can hear the ocean and hear the
scene so me eating uni is like eating
the seeds it's like tasting this it's
like it's you know like if the she had
poop and you ate it it would be
if the seeds were like the best flavored
poop if if if that's if that is true
poop just just i i i guess
i'm a [ __ ]
i guess i'm about to play euphoria all
over again baby because i i am a seed
lover if you know what it is it's on
screen right now it says orange looking
paste thingy you'll you'll recognize it
because it always stands out in the
sushi yeah everything it looks like
one of these things is not like the
other
but it looks it's so refreshing
so you'll know which camp you're in yeah
it's
when you try it please let me know to be
fair
i think out of like the almost like
maybe 10 to 20 people that i've taken to
a sushi place and they've tried uni i
think like like 75 of them ended up
liking it yeah what i think it's like
most people i think are very thrown off
with how it looks i spoke to dadas and
emily and they were like yeah they were
like let's go to a sushi place like sure
like the one place i don't want to go is
if they have too much uni
and i was like don't worry i hate uni
too
yes that's so good no taste no taste no
taste but oh yeah like i i really really
like uni and i even if you don't like it
i recommend you try it out because
it's a very unique flavor it's very
refreshing it's nothing
it's nowhere on the same level as like
something like [ __ ] natto or
something like that where it's like
weird foods it's a very subtle flavor
subtle it's like a it's a bomb going off
no it's not what no
it's like refreshing it's like eating
the ocean it's like it's like a salty
creamy type of like you know nice flavor
that goes yeah yeah
it's so weird because you literally look
at the sea urchin and just like how the
[ __ ] anything edible come out of that
it's like what the hell is this they
crack it open gold
gold of the ocean
um okay i would probably recommend then
um what japan does really [ __ ] well
when when we think of meat based foods
in japan you know most people are pretty
quick to go like uh you know wagyu and
stuff like that i think they're like
tonkatsu in japan oh yeah it's god tiff
[ __ ] which is uh which is uh
uh fried no not fried well deep yeah
like pork dude if you ever go to gunma
holy [ __ ] these things are like yeah
they look like they're fighting back
thick pieces of pork it's so good though
oh there's this really good chain in
tokyo
i'm going to call my sin yeah oh my set
dude my son is god here uh did i took
you there yeah i told connor and it's
like 40 bucks though but like holy [ __ ]
but it is the best poor color you'll
ever have oh
my gosh
oh
yeah pork cutlet like there's there's
nothing that can be like a fresh pork
cutlet hungover it's my go-to yeah yeah
it's just like shrimp has the egg [ __ ]
yeah
like the texture is just godly you bite
in and it's all crispy and then you get
the rich inside it's nice and juicy oh
my god [ __ ] me out god
you can have it by itself or there's
another really like cool way to eat it
which i like which is katsudon yeah
which is like where you like put it in
an egg and like have some money people
that are a better right yeah
i'm not a fan of katsudon really because
it's like to me to me
to me part of my like one of my favorite
things about tonkatsu is the texture
right but when you put it on the egg it
just like it gets rid of that crunch to
it no but like it's written but that's
replaced with the [ __ ] amazing like
egg and like pork flavored
all that turns your
it's that crunch it's that fresh crunch
that just it's it's just godly and by
putting egg over it you get a fresh one
you can get like the crunch with the egg
and the sauce and the you got them you
gotta you have the cuts on the licen
dude it has the crunch i can't believe
you just tell me what it is i can't
believe it tell you what it tell you
what it is it's it's like putting milk
in your cereal all right
you get rid of the texture you i like
that crunch i like that fresh crunch
chatted on is better than the normal uh
cause you get the egg the egg and the
onions are a game changer but with the
rice because when you get the perfect
ratio of of meat egg rice and onions in
one bite it's like it's like food wars
levels
it's it's the best i don't know what go
on god's little baby though god's like
dude gonna ask questions like do you
peel your crayons before you eat it like
yes like i don't know don't don't trust
god
i mean i mean it's it's it's it's a
prayer it's a preference thing it's a
preference i've got so to me to me the
best thing about tonkatsu is to eat [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] what you do no no no no
no he's got good taste because he likes
uni natto all right you want to side
with a guy who says old bread tastes the
same
but i will agree uni and nato has gone
live they're [ __ ] godlike yeah but
again like i would like to argue there
is so much more to japanese cuisine than
sushi and wagyu like yeah go ahead eat
the sushi
and ramen right all [ __ ] amazing but
if you go out there and try out some
other like lesser-known stuff and
there's like we only just [ __ ]
scratched the surface there is plenty of
other stuff
maybe maybe you're like oh [ __ ] i [ __ ]
with economics
you know takoyaki as well you know it
kind of chooses uh yeah some people
really like it some people don't there's
some really nice restaurants actually
that do it that are like really good
prices
it i mean it's street food right but
there are some restaurants that do it
amazingly but if you're gonna have some
of the best okonomiyaki and takoyaki
especially you've got to go to osaka
that's true yeah
the best the okonomiyaki the best
okonomiyaki i had was in osaka in like
this like really shitty downtown
where like five people could fit in it
and it was [ __ ] amazing well the
thing is it's just like i feel like the
rule with asian food is that if you buy
it on the streets or if it looks [ __ ]
dirty that food is gonna [ __ ] be
amazing and then and that rule is also
consistent in japan as well if you have
the if you have the opportunity to buy
street food it's not it's normally
[ __ ] amazing yeah i've got a question
what about conbini food where does that
come into this combini food um company
food is an experience i think that's
really fun for the first couple of days
yeah yeah obviously you're gonna want
you're gonna want to save some money and
spend some money on restaurants but i'd
say yeah yeah you could definitely gotta
try to food's still
great compared to everywhere else
because i'm like
i'm like compared to the rest of the
world compared to the restaurant because
like i'm remembering when i first came
to japan i'm just like damn i can live
out of 7-eleven and family my entire
life and i did for like a good few
months and didn't get bored you guys
lived off conveniently like onigirian
sandwiches yeah yeah yeah
because like compared to like the food
we have uh like [ __ ] tesco's or
whatever it's like
[ __ ]
okay listen right these sandwiches are
good they're decent but these sandwiches
aren't better than the ones i'm
reserving my judgment i still have yet
to try a tesco meal deal
i know for a fact i know when we go to
the uk for god's wedding later right
yeah i'm going to try it out and i'll
see which side i'm he's pretty scared
because i know for a fact you're going
to like the tesco meal deal more okay
but like comparing tesco food to [ __ ]
combini food it's it's nowhere near it's
nowhere near yeah okay first of all joe
here's i'm going to tell you first of
all sandwiches actually have crust on
them okay that already wins all right
what do you what what what do you want
if you don't want a sandwich
no i'm not saying i'm okay i'm just
saying the sandwich is about it all
right okay that's that's not an argument
i'm saying conbini food in general would
you want what do you want if you want to
tesco muddy but you don't want a
sandwich get a salad sorry it's decent
it's not great i'm looking at a
cornbread [ __ ] salad pasty if you're
on pasta it's a cold pasty a cold pasta
it's like a pork ball with batter
egg no egg in the middle yeah you gotta
you gotta compare that to like [ __ ]
good good fried chicken
but the sandwich game is absolutely
appalling i still like them yeah but the
uk sandwiches are like it's like
like the sandwich there's the sandwich
in kombini's section is like one one
tiny section compared to like literally
what's up with that why is that a meal
deal why is that a drink get your own
tea get a sandwich and a little snack
because you have an infinite amount of
choice yeah yeah
like just called going to the food
section at a convenience also i don't
like in japan how it's really hard to
get a normal sized bag of crisps like
they're all big sized right you notice
that yeah it's like you can't you talk
about like the small you can't just have
like one portion of crisp it's like you
have you're committing to like three
bags yeah would it be fair to be fair
though like when you when you do buy the
big ones though like 60 of it is air
which is probably the equivalent to like
one small sized bag of chips so yeah but
yeah i mean like if especially if you
come from england uh i think connor's
romanticized tesco muir deals absolutely
not because you got these sandwiches and
uh if you go to the company you also
have sandwiches but you also have like
onigiri fried chicken you have some
yakitori sticks you got bentos
i don't [ __ ] with the yakitori sticks at
conbini's i wouldn't get them you won't
get them so you get like you get like
you've got fried chicken beef balls have
the sausages there before
did you get food poisoning from them i
did not i've had the 7-eleven like not
corn dogs the ones like just hot dogs on
a stick yeah it's all right the corn
dogs at 7-eleven are kind of all right
no i've never had one i i like corn dogs
it's hard to [ __ ] up a corn dog if you
go to a mini stop which you won't see
often they have soft serves they are the
rarest yeah although many stop soft
serves are godliness yeah yeah like they
specialize in soft surf and it's it's it
goes hard but finding it but like mini
stops are like the ssrs yeah
i think in tokyo i think it's only like
0.5 percent of companies in tokyo are
mini stops most of them i feel like are
around like shinjuku weirdly i see a lot
yeah i know there's one like up north
where i used to live but that was very
rare they get though i was very happy i
lived near a mini stop i was like oh yes
i've pulled the ssr let's go babies
so much just so you're supposed to
choice with food and how about however
much you want to spend you can spend
yeah yeah i guess we've gotten a lot of
the basic things out of the way of like
your first visit to japan what if what
if someone has a little bit more time
and has been to japan a few times where
would you guys recommend that they go to
well i mean i you know we did this the
shima nami kaido which is on the cycling
special honestly
like that inland sea area is [ __ ]
beautiful gorgeous [ __ ] incredible
and i've really really since the cycling
special i really want to go back there
like i really want to go back there and
do the route again basically just just
look at the spike this just look at the
cycling special and just look how
[ __ ] beautiful it was because the
best thing about it is that like you
have you know all of like hiroshima
that's near there you have right next to
that there's a prefecture called okayama
yeah uh where i went there for a video
um
there's this like little small town
called kuroshki which is like this
really [ __ ] cool retro style town
that's just basically just like this
hill that overlooks the inland sea and
it's so [ __ ] gorgeous and then if you
want to cross that inland sea and go to
like shikoku uh yeah you have places
like ehime which is really like kind of
down to earth and like kind of chill
yeah
okay
not the most it's not the most exciting
thing but like if you're a little bored
of like yeah if you're a little bored of
like the kind of whole city life of
tokyo and stuff like that in the main
cities uh that's really really nice yeah
and if uh if watching the cycling
special kind of like intimidated you uh
don't worry you don't need to do the
entire route in a day um if i was to do
it again i would definitely not do it in
a day you can also rent a car just drive
across you can also rent a car but if
you also want to keep healthy you know
keep keep
you know work out those muscles then i
do actually highly i highly recommend
the cycling route um i highly recommend
you doing that in uh two days maybe
three days you know how well if
now that you think back what was what do
you think is like the optimal time you
would recommend i would call that a day
we still do in a day yeah i reckon if i
didn't want to be hurting i'd say at
least two days i think it was just
annoying because we were filming i think
it would have been not pretty fun if you
could just power up there's a couple of
like the islands in between where
admittedly there isn't a whole lot going
on but like the first couple of islands
uh you know that's like closer to like
hiroshima there's like still a really
like cool like town vibe to it and you
know there's like a lot of like cool
beaches there as well so if you go yeah
yeah it's like there's some genuinely
nice beaches there's a fit you are i
guess if you really aren't fit at all i
wouldn't yeah maybe just stick to the
first island yeah yeah yeah but you know
if you're somewhat active and you you
know you'll have no problem cycling then
yeah i'd just do it on one day it's very
you can also just cycle around hiroshima
as well yeah yeah i mean honestly it's
like some of the most beautiful views
i've had in japan yeah i'm not saying a
lot because a lot of japan is photogenic
as [ __ ]
so it's a bit unfair i mean i i guess
sticking on that vein um if you want to
go see mount fuji um i do recommend
going to one of the lakes around there i
can't remember the name exactly but like
school how good should you go
like we like lake kawaguchiko is just
like you can also cycle around there you
can rent a bike me and you've
gone on a date where we've rented the
bike and just cycled around the entire
lake
it's kind of unfair where you go to a
place and everything looks photoshopped
even though it's real like you you take
a picture there we've taken a bunch of
pictures there i don't know we've uh
when the last time we went there was the
uh we went camping right when we went
camping yeah and luke took a bunch of
pictures and we took a bunch of pictures
and everyone took a bunch of pictures
and nowhere
i know and no matter what it was
impossible to take a bad picture it just
looked like a postcard especially when
it's clear yeah yeah yeah yeah which it
was when we went very lucky yeah but um
yeah
yeah i don't know because like i
remember when we did the journey across
japan two to mount fuji yeah a lot of
people thought that by the end of it we
had just like green screened ourselves
in front of it because it just looked
that good it's it's it's so weird being
in that place and you just like i
literally look like
i let you feel like i'm looking at the
green screen or like it's this is a this
is a screen saver right like a desktop
yeah i'm looking at a screen saying i'm
waiting for the pipes animation to see
yeah it's it's so surreal that a place
can look that photogenic but just exist
in real life without any uh without any
plug-ins or any uh any photoshop edits
on no yeah yeah yeah no rtx on well it's
probably one of the places you might
want to drive though it's kind of
annoying to go by train and stuff yeah
there isn't a whole lot of traffic i'd
say like outside of the major cities
like osaka um tokyo sapporo and stuff
like that um driving this driving is
your best friend you literally like
you'll have such a hard time if you're
trying to do it by public transport as
i'm sure
probably is uh experience because you
only do all by public transport yeah
yeah actually uh on that vein i guess an
app i highly recommend uh is the app
that we use is a dd
which um there are there is like a few
taxi apps in japan uh
taxi but uh dd is the most i guess
foreigner friendly because it's you can
uh full english so it's all english so
except for any card yeah it will accept
any card with with other apps it's been
really finicky with the types of cards
that it will accept japan taxi and go
taxi whatever it is now oh yeah god it
is i have a japanese card and she keeps
denying it really i have a japanese card
it denies it i have it so annoying i
have a foreign card it denies it i have
like cards from like
like thailand and the uk and it's just
like it doesn't want to accept anything
it doesn't accept anything so i don't
know what card it will accept
um so yeah i like highly recommend dd
over uber here would you say sorry
because i know you can use uber if you
want yeah you can use uber but uh
whatever you're comfortable with yeah i
think i think dd is i think there's more
taxis on dd um yeah and it's and it's
the best in between because dd is not as
popular as a japanese app like go taxi
but it is still way more friendly if you
unfortunately uber is just not really a
thing here no uber uber ubereats is but
like the actual uber i know i know some
people who use it religiously yeah um
but mainly for food i guess yeah yeah
also hailing cabs is really really easy
here
especially in tokyo if you you know if
you're confident enough and just telling
them where to go uh it's really easy
yeah obviously that's a big if yeah i
understand it's at all but i think for
the most part if you're in tokyo the
train system is just so convenient you
probably google very rarely will have to
don't try to learn the maps just use
google maps yeah it's pretty simple it
routes it out for
is absolutely lying google literally
knows the best route i'm i'm i wish that
people would shut up being like i know
the streets better no you don't google
google has every [ __ ] satellite in
existence and billions of data it knows
whether to be fair there has been times
where i've looked at google and i'm like
nah dude you're going you're gonna like
deal you're gonna like the aesthetic
route sometimes sometimes google wants
to like make your life easier to a point
where it's like listen it's just quicker
if i just walk yeah yeah yeah they're
like no no we're gonna make it so you
don't walk it um
yeah but generally for if you're only
getting you're gonna have to change
three different trains if you wanna get
a to z google will generally tell you
the best way and you could tell it to
fewer changes or more changes
yeah it's i've it's never failed me in
tokyo yeah even outside of tokyo i'm
driving i use it for driving i use it i
bought one of those shitty little things
on amazon that you stick on like the air
fans oh yeah yeah phone hold your phone
yeah man yeah it's good i'm good
is there any other places you guys would
recommend a bit out of the box
i've never been to kyushu i already
think joey is good kyushu is great uh i
i think kyushu is underrated as hell
yeah um i one place i really really
liked in kyushu was um kumamoto yeah
yeah where aso is the volcano mount also
is yeah but like i think kumamoto is
really cool because it's like it's again
this like huge like volcanic caldera but
it's also like it weirdly reminds me a
lot of like the kind of like plain uh
open plain places that i went to a lot
in like australia and like in england
and stuff like that yeah it doesn't look
like japan right and it's so weird but
like it's really really cool if you like
your like kind of mountainous areas it's
really dope and also you're really close
to like nagasaki as well which is a
really dope city um nagasaki is a super
cool city that's like very like vintage
feel it has like a very european feel as
well because like a lot of the a lot of
like european settlers came in and out
of nagasaki um
yeah i don't know kyushu i think is
really underrated has some really good
food as well as one of the game yeah
that's really cool yeah i still haven't
been to kyushu as well you can go to as
well which has the other really massive
onsen area
mean to hiroshima it's like five hours
all right
and that's not even in kyushu yeah yeah
yeah yeah i mean like i guess one place
that i don't really hear people talking
about is obviously like if you're a wine
lover like me and sydney are uh you can
go to the wine capital of japan even
though like wines not as well known here
but i mean we discovered the place
because we're not like i'm not a big
sake fan
i'm not a massive sake fan but there are
plenty of places to try sake in tokyo
and basically anywhere you go into japan
but if you want to have a little taste
of the japanese wine culture here
because it's not very well talked about
you go to koshu valley it's in the
yamanashi prefecture which is like you
can literally make it a day trip oh you
wanted to um it's like just about like
an hour an hour and a half out of tokyo
uh you can literally just go on on the
jr line and go to
go to the stops around kosher valley um
there is one place i do recommend if you
are interested uh i believe the building
is called budo budonooka i think
yeah um great hill yeah yeah great grave
hill um i believe that's the place uh
because that's the place i've talked
about before where you can go in and
they have a wine cellar with about a
hundred different wines you pay 13 bucks
and you can try as many wines as you
like and uh
it's self poor they give you they give
you a they give you a little cup and uh
you can try as many ones as you like
there's there's little bowls where you
can spit out the wine if you don't like
the taste of the wine you know
um actually just 13 bucks to get mounted
on wine yeah i've done it i've done it
plenty of [ __ ] times it's a really
really good experience and then there's
a really nice restaurant up there um
where you can see the entire view of
koshi valley and you can see all the
grape farms and all the grape vines
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't look like japan yeah it's
it's it's got such a good [ __ ] view
um and me and cindy go in there for a
yearly trip uh to try out the different
wines there that come out every year
yeah you can i i think i drove there in
this decent parking but if you do like
sake i would recommend niigato you got
to ah yeah is like the capital of sake
and like rice fields and stuff yeah i
went to a similar
thing like to the winery except it was
all sake
for like 20 bucks and you could like
taste test yeah
yeah
it's basically like all throughout
niigata it's just like all really really
nice like sake based on something
to it yeah so if you like sake go to
niigata if you like wine go to yamaha
but also in the negative vending
machines the there's
it's like nectar of the gods
it's wonderful it's just like
sugary goodness oh it's so good it's
very good it's so bad for you though
yeah like 100 sugar watching yume is a
bit too sweet for my palate otherwise i
probably would like i couldn't drink it
straight but like you know you're mixing
it up like soda yeah yeah i mean
it's pretty
i've been there a bunch it's okay
there's not really much to do there but
the vending machine is sick yeah but
there are ski resorts near it so in the
winter if you're coming
which is a really very popular decent
ski resort and in tokyo area in general
no one really goes to but it's pretty
chill i've been there a town obviously
with chris sure you have as well yeah i
love to army and talkers my family's
from talks yeah right i mean sendai's
chill yeah
it's fun
abroad in japan studio of course
i mean
it's fun we've been there a bunch yeah
fukushima yeah oh yeah we're drifting in
yeah we went we went drifting there a
lot of cool areas of the north that
doesn't really ever get spoken about as
a tourist destination yeah i think it's
because talk is just so big
a lot of the biggest like i mean i think
iwate is the second biggest prefecture
after hokkaido it's a cool place though
i've had some really amazing food and
drink in that area and it's just kind of
nice to go somewhere because especially
if like kyoto is too touristy for you
yeah definitely
oh yeah you're not gonna have tourists
definitely yeah uh and it's it's a good
time way way always have fun with krista
yeah because i mean like especially like
one of the biggest things about kyoto is
that it's just like too crowded and you
can get it's like proud of even now and
i don't know is it crowded now that's
sort of crowded i mean uh i don't know
some some seasons i've been it's been
dead it depends on the day you go
obviously weekdays is dead yeah um but
um some weekends are still busy so i'm
like god forbid
you come here on a on a like
peak tourist is there like a prefecture
or like area of japan you've always
wanted to go to but you haven't been
yeah
i really still haven't been to and
really want to go to aomori oh i want to
get home
because it's like it's in between
hokkaido and the yeah like
i'm just like why would i not just go to
hokkaido at that point yeah all morning
has like really cool like you can do
like apple pickles
for really good food like really nice
like winter wonderland places yeah i've
heard it's really fun
what about um theme parks because uh
you've never been i'm not huge i mean
you've still been to disneyland though
haven't you yeah i don't like disney
though i'm awful i'm the wrong person
yeah i don't i don't like theme parks
either but usj is pretty fun in all
soccer i've been to the usj yeah yeah
it's decent you just said you've not
been to any theme parks you've literally
lived
you've literally been to like two of the
biggest all the big the biggest one fuji
q i haven't been to so i feel like my
opinion doesn't count but like yeah i
mean fujiku is more like the six flags
right it's it's the thrill scene yeah i
i like thrill rides and i was kind of
disappointed by usg i thought there's
gonna be more thrill rides i don't know
why i think you're better off in fuji
yeah i figured like i'll put it like
fujiki more
because i hate thrill rides
and i'm like oh if you love thrall rides
this is yeah
you can go to a roller coaster and have
a view of fuji how how awesome is that
right like that's that's pretty badass
yeah where where's where is where's
thought park with that
what does thought park out what the [ __ ]
is thought park have the car park ah
like well park's good what the [ __ ] are
you on about it is good it is good it
just said just like how can it like you
know
i i think fuji i mean fuji is just like
one of the best have you been to
you've been to fuji queue i've i've been
outside it and i'm like well i've driven
past it
no [ __ ] on thought park hold on
i'm not i'm not sitting on thor park but
um i mean we all drove past fuji q when
we went [ __ ] camping i am did we yeah
i was [ __ ] asleep
i didn't remember that but like it was
just it was just a really nice aesthetic
area i don't know i just like
it's good but you know i mean come on
snow snow it can't be no thought no no
nemesis inferno you guys no it's not in
town so is it
it's about old town's are so good we
gotta take you i think all the theme
parks though yeah okay he literally just
said he's really like i don't like
thorough rides or theme parks i thought
you're just joking no i don't
[ __ ] usj n usj nintendo land is
the only one i liked but that's obvious
because i'm a nintendo scene why don't
you what why i don't i'd rather go
[ __ ] to the arcade or watch a movie
but yeah i mean is there anything else
you guys want to mention not off the top
of my head yeah japan's great that's all
like that's our like starter guide to
having a fun time in japan yeah start a
guide obviously obviously
two-hour podcast yeah obviously we
haven't all gone to every single
location in japan like i've eventually
would like to go to every single
prefecture in japan that's like my life
goal but um yeah it's still a lot i
haven't been so a lot of stuff i love
going to just like yeah it's just good
food in it yeah
honestly honestly like us like we said
earlier a lot of a lot of the big draw
of uh going traveling now is just trying
the food in that prefecture trying to
fill in that area because [ __ ] if if
there's like we said all uh earlier the
food here is absolutely amazing and
that's the real you know you don't come
here for the anime figures you don't
come here for like the [ __ ] temples
you come here for the amazing food
that's the real reason to come to japan
just go out there and just try a bunch
of everything yeah try everything
you know people come here for like the
[ __ ] sakura blossoms you're gonna
take a few pictures and then you're
gonna have the amazing food okay that's
that's it that's it
the sakura is only amazing to watch at
because you're [ __ ] sipping on some
like super nice sake or eating something
yeah
yeah exactly
it all comes back
it all comes back to the food okay i
literally revolve my trips in japan
around like the restaurants in the field
it sounds like a joke but it's really
not like that's that's the highlight of
my trip a lot of the time you know if
you go to japan then this episode is
somewhat helpful to you please let us
know at some point we'd love to uh maybe
not right now when this episode goes
live but maybe in a few months you might
use it or yeah
and let us know if any of the tips are
useful we'd love to know what you liked
and didn't like about this episode but
you know who especially loves japan oh
patrons oh oh beautiful people they
would all love japan of course they
would oh they're so good because they
definitely don't love anime
they love the show
which means they love japan they love
they watched trash day so they
definitely don't watch it because uh the
anime but hey if you'd like to support
the show then go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify [ __ ] yes i'm going to go eat
some food and then sleep yeah we
i'm [ __ ] starving is there one nearby
this office because i want i want some
good food i want some good food let's go
all right see you guys next week bye
[Music]
you